over this past holiday weekend in the
past week it's been pretty wild in
Europe we've had some pretty serious
stories about children being Gravely
injured or killed by by uh immigrants in
one story it is quoted as the man saying
we are here to stab white people so
there there are now there have been
riots in Dublin over this with Conor
McGregor speaking out saying we are at
War and slamming politicians for forcing
immigrants into these parts of Ireland
you've got a video of shin fine which is
the leftist political party in Ireland
getting heckled and in France in Lion
you've got protests in the street people
saying France wake up you're under
attack and so it's getting particularly
interesting especially when you consider
G Wilders winning in Holland and the
media reporting is the far right winning
but I will say only this before we get
started because we have a lot of other
stories too we'll talk domestic stuff I
think it's funny that if the majority of
the populations of Europe are electing
politicians would they not be the
moderate choices that the majority is
supporting how could they be the far
right if the majority support them they
would just be the average wouldn't they
except to the media to the press to the
political class they are in opposition
to you and to the majority who are
electing these politicians so it's
particularly interesting how they're
framing it before we get started my
friends head over to cast brew.com this
show is brought to you by the best cup
of coffee you'll ever have go to cast
brew and buy our limited edition rise
with Roberto Jr I know it's been quite a
quite a way a while since Halloween but
we are doing this blend one time and one
time only once they're gone they're gone
forever we did order 5,000 of them so
we'll see how long it takes for this
disappear but get it while you can now
Appalachia kns I guess we only have
three bags left of the ground coffee is
extremely popular and we also have kups
cast Brew is our coffee product it
sponsors the show and we are also
building physical locations currently
underway if you want to support the
mission to create physical spaces to
hang out and get them all over the
country go to cpw.com but also don't
forget go to
timcast.net fun so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more is Brian Lup thanks for having
me who are you what do you do uh my name
is Brian Lupo I I'm a writer for the
Gateway pundit I uh run uh a couple
shows over on Badlands media on Rumble
um I go by can Con on my own podcast
stands for cannabis conservative uh you
cover a lot of uh election stuff a lot
of J sixer stuff yeah a lot of election
lot of j6 um um you know it's it's
skating on thin ice you know here you
don't really ever know what you can say
and all that stuff but uh YouTube just
gave Crowder two strikes for hosting Dan
Bonino they really don't Dan B really
don't like Dan but but this violates
their own policies YouTube claims their
policy is you can have people on the
show who have been banned so long as
they aren't hosting shows Crowder had
banino on his show as a guest and they
gave him strike over it they're not
consistent they're playing politics for
sure but anyway anyway we'll get into
all that stuff thanks for hanging out it
be fun we got Hannah Clair hanging out
hey I'm Hannah Clair brimo I'm a writer
for scanner news now I used to be with
timcast news and we've just evolved you
know how it is and we're here of course
with Libby Emmons hey Hannah CLA nice to
be here nice to be here hanging out I'm
Libby Emmons I am the editor-in-chief
with the post millennial and human
events.com
and I am surge.com I hope you guys had a
wonderful Thanksgiving weekend I
definitely did Let's uh get to it Tim
this story is wild I'm sure most of you
have already heard about the riots
happening in Dublin it was uh several
children were stabbed and in in critical
condition I I believe two of the
children I could be wrong have been
released is it two I only know of one
being released One released okay so
let's start here with this story from uh
this is from the Independent aggregated
by Yahoo Conor McGregor reacts to Dublin
riots after declaring Ireland is at War
for this he is under Criminal investig
this is how crazy it is take a look
Conor McGregor said he does not condone
the rids in Dublin but insisted that a
change must occur after a knife attack
left five people injured including three
children I like say I like how they say
five people just say three children and
two adults a five-year-old girl was left
in critical condition after an attack in
Dublin on Thursday November 23rd which
led to Violent protests in the Irish
capital I will add some of the videos of
looting clearly not over immigration it
is a bunch of people just smash smashing
and stealing stuff and they're saying oh
they're far right no those guys that's
opportunistic we see those we see that
happen all the time but what we are
seeing is a lot of the Nationalist
Personalities in Europe pointing out
that the the indigenous populations of
these countries the white majority and
and and natives to these lands are are
are actually protesting they're actually
riding it's not just in Dublin we'll get
into more details in a in a minute on
France we'll talk about that another
segment but even in France you had I
believe it was an Algerian immigrant mhm
threatening uh uh they're here to stab
white people and then a teenager was
stabbed and killed so now you are
getting people pushing back let me let
me add to this I was hanging out with
friends this past holiday weekend and a
friend of mine uh introduced us to a
friend who was from Holland who is like
I would describe as left liberal
individual out of Europe who explained
that the right is winning because
they're all sick of immigration and she
went on to explain in her very thick
Dutch accent about there are too many
people that coming and they're they're
getting money from the government and
people are really fed up and I was like
wow now this is interesting because then
gear Wilder's party wins and this is
what we're seeing it fascinating this is
this is crazy uh eight eight years ago
you couldn't say men aren't women on
Twitter you would be banned now we're
see we are seeing nationalist
politicians winning more right sentiment
you're seeing Donald Trump winning among
18 to 34 year olds in more than one poll
NBC News is kind of pissed off about it
but we're seeing a lot of this now Conor
McGregor has another tweet let me see if
I can pull this one up he tweeted our
current government leader recently told
communities across Ireland he is
actually not asking them for permission
to plant multiple busloads of people in
the dead of night inside their Community
he is instead telling them we well now
it seems From Below said communities are
not going to ask him if they may stop if
they may stop them how do we feel I feel
transparency is the answer full
information should be attained and
divulged to gain support from the
communities of Ireland for this new
peculiar procedure that has begun over
the course of this year 2023 without it
fear Panic unrest can't we come to our
senses here take a look at this it say
in County lrim Irish men and women have
set a checkpoint to prevent Asylum
Seekers from being planted in their town
of course for this Irish police are
investigating Conor McGregor over his
tweets it's getting crazy I don't want
to jump too much into it because now
we've got more reports that they're
passing these Draconian hate speech laws
to ban this stuff I got to say man
Ireland occupied territory yeah Ireland
doesn't want your memes anymore
Ireland's trying to prevent that's
that's seriously part of their new laws
I mean one of the issues here is that
this uh is such a tragic the Optics on
this are so tragic because not only was
it young children but it's young
children being walked to after school
care after departing an an all Irish
School meaning they only instruct in the
Gaelic language and so this is obviously
to the core of Irish culture something
they feel like they would want to
protect their language and their
children I mean even the stories coming
out of it right I think it was uh they
were saying a Brazilian bike messenger
is the one who like ultimately knocked
this guy out with his helmet and pinned
him to the ground well was interesting
too because it it was the there were
reports that it was an Algerian
immigrant and then immediately yeah the
BBC and all of these other outlets were
like it wasn't an Algerian immigrant he
was an immigrant 20 years ago
he's not different that's different and
it turns out he's never had a job you
know he's been living on the do the
whole time yes and when you look at that
it's absolutely insane and those those
hate speech laws um one of the one of
the parts of that law it says a hate
crime is any criminal offense any
criminal offense which is perceived by
the victim or any other person to have
been motivated by Prejudice based on a
person's age disability race color
nationality ethnicity religion sexual
orientation or gender so it's any
criminal offense perceived as being
motivated which means the government
decides regardless it's messed up but do
you think this guy who perpetrated this
attack would be charged with a hate
crime no of course not well they're
saying that he was mentally deranged or
something because he was arrested for
illegal knife possession earlier this
year and let go cries are up all over
right because he was like mentally a
problem anyone who goes out and stabs
children is mentally deranged it's not
an excuse for the behavior nor is it is
it an answer uh uh to the complaints and
the questions of the of the indigenous
population who are concerned about an
individual who was actually slated to be
deported fought it and was able to stay
and then in 2008 and then went on to uh
uh stay in the country now I'm not sure
that in this I what I don't want to do
is take an a single anecdote and say aha
immigration but the the issue is they
they have not addressed it they have
punished the people who lived there and
they have helped Foster a very
anti-immigration sentiment where all it
takes is one story like this and that's
the Tinder that's the spark for the
powder Ki my wife and I were in Ireland
in 2018 and uh we were out there for a
week and like we we spent like three or
four days I think in Dublin and we
didn't see like I didn't see any of this
I everybody there was Irish so I I guess
I guess this is something that's come up
in the last 5 years or so I know
England's got a lot of issues there
there's there's they they kind of settle
themselves into their own little
isolated Burrows and stuff are they
doing the same thing in Ireland but this
is this is the look I I grew up in
Chicago you walk around Chicago you're
not getting shot at right however
Chicago has more shootings than I think
at one point they call they called it
shyak because Chicago had more shooting
deaths than Iraq did but any tourist who
goes there is like I don't see anything
like this yeah the question is are you
in the neighborhoods are you and have
you have you witnessed the changes so
when I went to Sweden several years ago
they they saw something like a
1,300% increase in murders now to
someone who doesn't know anything that
sounds terrifying like
1,300% yeah it's because they went from
one murder the year before to 13 murders
and so it the number is shocking if
you're from the United States you're
imagining Baltimore when someone's like
the crimes through the roof the murders
are up a th% you're like whoa you're
imagining crime in the United States
which is it can be bad if you're from
the United States and you go to Sweden
you're like wait your town of 350,000
had only 13 murders wow I mean that's
bad but like come to the United States
yeah the percentages seems cute but for
the people who live there that's a lot
they don't have murder and not only that
they're having grenade attacks they had
they had I think they they have the
record for grenade attacks in a single
year in Sweden yeah and it's because
people who don't who aren't from there
are coming in and they're bringing I
believe it was from like um what war was
it there was it's been so long since I
covered this there were leftover weapons
used in war and the gangs got easy
access to them and started using them
against each other so there was like an
8-year-old British tourist I think was
was was killed in a grenade attack or
something like that around the time I I
had showed up had shown up so the point
is if you live if if your country is a
sleepy peaceful country with no murder
and they open their doors to immigration
murder skyrockets people are going to
protest and the the media manipulation
in the lies from government officials I
mean it's it's it it only lasts so long
the the censorship the manipulation
social media censorship it's only so
long until people just snap and say no
way and I think especially with Ireland
the UK's uh the way the UK treated their
Asylum Seekers ultimately Creeps in even
if they potentially didn't want it so 5
years ago maybe they fought it harder
but Northern Ireland which is obviously
in the same physical land is Ireland
even though it's part of the UK the
number one baby name in gallway was
Muhammad in 2022
people were shocked by that people were
completely shocked but they were like oh
it's Liam nope no not Jack well the
average size of their family is
significantly bigger than anybody in
Europe I mean which is crazy when you
consider the Irish Catholics like they
had big big families now it's down to
like 1 I think I think Europe like
averages like 1.5 children per family
and like I think anything less than 1.7
it's unsustainable ultimately immigra is
is it two well if two people only make
one kid that's a good point no I think
the thing is ultimately immigration
issues are a long-term negative
investment right like opening your doors
to some immigration a lot of countries
start with like oh we're we're a sleepy
T we can offer stuff we're wealthy and
then ultimately they don't see the
investment or they don't see the
implications of what they are investing
in long term which is that bringing
someone into your country because you
believe they're seeking Asylum might be
an honorable thing to do but acclimating
someone to your culture and to
everything that comes with being a
citizen is a long-term uh plan and I I
think Mass immigration is a sustainable
way to do that ultimately I think that's
a big part of the problem what you just
hit on is you know in the US we had a
lot of immigration in the 20th century
we've had that repeatedly but the
immigrants who came in the 20th century
in the early 20th century 1920s whenever
all of that Ellis Island type of stuff
they wanted to assimilate they wanted to
become American you know I've talked
about this before like my grandparents
my great-grandparents they wanted to be
American they wanted their kids to be
American they pushed English on them you
know my grandparents both change my
Italian grandparents changed their names
to be more American sounding my
grandmother went from Anna to an she was
like I'm just an now okay you know they
want it to America but now we have this
thing where we tell everybody that
American culture is trash and they
shouldn't want to be part of it and they
should bring their own culture and
maintain that and it's like once we've
given up our own culture and said that
it's garbage why would we expect anyone
else to want to be part of it well
Denver just um I was just reading this
report today that Denver is uh trying to
make it so they're encouraging students
like who have immigrated here to
continue to speak their own language and
not to learn English this is W that's so
dumb that's just so stupid I got I was
hanging out with the family for the
holidays and my girlfriend's very based
grandmother we we were looking at photos
of you know her her parents Came From
Italy and she's 90 this is crazy crazy
it's it's amazing to see these old
photos and hear these stories and she
said that her parents never taught her
Italian and so she comes their parents
come here she's born here and she said I
wish they did teach me Italian but they
said we're we're in America we will
speak English and she said they spoke
broken English but they tried their
hardest to learn the language and work
in the communities and make a good life
and that's what they did now they have a
bunch of great kids and a big big family
and uh it's it's crazy to see the
expansion of the family tree but I I
feel like especially for uh you know the
the the elements of my family that were
immigrants same thing come to America
learn the language fit in try your best
even when back then it's hard for you
know my family because of the laws
around misation mixed race families are
not allowed and stuff like that for
white Europeans it's a bit easier but
even still the attempt was we have to do
our best to fit in we have to be a part
of this is a success and we're investing
in this experiment right we want to be a
part of growing this nation and our our
way of contributing to that is to be a
part of the culture and actively have
our children participate and carry that
forward and that's not the way it works
now and that's like the the strange
thing we'll get progressive saying no we
should let immigrant enclaves live this
way and and maintain their culture
because we're allowing American culture
to die out I want to jump to this story
this is from op India they wanted to die
out yes yes here's a story from op India
Washington Post and BBC falsely claim
the Dublin attacker was not an immigrant
here is the truth I love this they got
they got community noted The Washington
Post tweets online rumors claimed the
perpetrator of a stabbing attack was an
immigrant the BBC found the man was an
Irish citizen who had lived in the
country for 20 years police blamed a
lunatic faction driven by a far-right
ideology for the riot in Dublin and then
uh here's the fact check the man is
indeed an immigrant as he was originally
from Algeria The Washington Post segment
appears to conflate citizenship with
being with not being an immigrant and
you can be both that's amazing so are
they blaming this on the far right are
they saying that he was far right well
so uh Carl Benjamin actually tweeted out
something an anecdote where someone said
an old lady was meant talking about you
know Ireland a guy mentioned going to
Ireland said did you hear about the
riots he said no and the woman said it
was something having the the far right
uh stabbed someone or something like
that this is what the media wants to
happen yeah that's why they're lying
about this person being an immigrant
they're TR this is it activists I think
it's simply put many of these media
organizations have activists who work
there the reason why the mainstream
corporate press is claiming that gear
Wilders and other politicians are far
right is because they are actually far
left if the majority of the population
is voting for a dude then that's the
median MH right or not necessarily the
median but that is the plurality or the
majority that is where most of people
see their views so that's not far or
anything that is right leaning right but
it seems far to them because they think
they are the truth over here on the
super far left the middle doesn't seem
they lie cheat and steal and this is
another element of it it's it's it's
laughable it was clearly an who did this
we can argue whether or not this single
anecdote is is exemplifies the entire
issue of immigration I don't think so I
think it's a data point but I do think
people are right to be upset when their
government refuses to listen to them and
then the media lies just like this to
trick people and some people fall for it
well then you have to put the far right
moniker on it so that then you can
justify the censorship and everything
else that's going to come as a result we
had the the woman in the Irish
Parliament uh was that recently uh
talking about taking away rights it was
in June yeah yeah you have your rights
well now you got Conor McGregor being
investigated for saying we're at War
which by the way that's happening here
that's happening here in the United
States Douglas Mackey is locked up over
a tweet you know from 20 uh 2016 my
co-host on Badlands on sitre he had the
FBI raid his house three weeks after
January 6th over a tweet he was not in
DC on January 6 what was his tweet we we
are at War this is and the the worst
part is in the warrant if you look two I
it was like a thread if you look two
tweets up he says we're in an
information war and he because they they
isolated that one tweet and said we're
in a war rolled up with Bearcats and up
armored vehicles at 6:00 a.m. to wake up
the whole neighborhood threw a flashbang
out there went into his house raided his
house found that he uh you know they
they took whatever they want the FBI
then they called in the the the local St
uh sheriff and they arrested arrested
him because he had a gun safe with an
AR-15 in it he was a cop he was a cop in
California but because he was I I think
he was like temporarily suspended while
there was an investigation I guess he
wasn't techn technically supposed to
have that so he was arrested and he's
still fighting them to this day that's
insane yes over a tweet yeah that
happens in the UK all the time like moms
have been investigated or arrested
handcuffed in front of their kids for
having posted that women aren't men
that's repeatedly you've had a situation
recently where a British guy um had
posted a video talking about all the
Palestinian Flags like up and down the
High Street and saying that he doesn't
like it and police showed up and in and
they dragged him off in handcuffs and
you had uh you know people screaming out
to the neighbors they're they're taking
him they're taking him in for a tweet
they're taking him in because he doesn't
like the flags down the block that's
just Madness where was that that was in
the UK that was in London that was in
London um you know that they had they've
had all those protests and there were
all these Palestinian Flags he posted a
video on Facebook that was like what is
all this doing here what about Tommy
Robinson do you guys see what happened
to him over the over the past weekend he
got arrested for no reason he's sitting
in a cafe eating breakfast and they come
and they say you have to leave or or or
else and and and it's actually funny
because he basically says okay pay for
my breakfast and they go no and I'm like
I actually kind of think that's a
reasonable position he should not have
to leave Tommy should be like bro you're
going to have to arrest me and and and
he kind of did say that but then
eventually he goes okay pay me back for
my breakfast and I'm like he's
essentially saying fine I'll leave give
me my money back and they're like we
won't do it they won't even do that I
did think it was funny that in the end
Tommy was actually being reasonable to
their demands when he didn't have to be
but they said you are what do they say
that you're causing harass you're the
potential for alarm or distress yeah so
therefore you're not he's he's in London
and they said by order of the city of
London which is I believe it's separate
from London to some degree
it's like in the middle and it's got
different police or something and uh
they're like you have to leave or else
and it was an anti-Semitism March and
the police arrested him and pepper
sprayed him while he was sitting in a
restaurant waiting for his breakfast
well and the articles that came out
about it indicated that he was
anti-semitic and he was at the
March like opposing anti-Semitism
covering it and there were some 50 cops
or whatever surrounding him to get him
out of there meanwhile like there's been
vandalism there's been people climbing
up on statues there's been all kinds of
Mayhem and those people are just let to
go by you know let's let's talk about
how they're going after the memes so
Nate Nate Hawkman tweets the hate speech
law that Ireland is preparing to pass is
arguably the most radical legislation of
its kind we've seen in the west it
criminalizes the mere possession of
materials that quote are likely to
incite violence or hatred books videos
or even memes on your phone look at this
this is amazing offense of preparing or
possessing material like to incite
violence or hatred against persons on
account of their protected
characteristics they say let's see a
subject to subject blah blah blah person
shall be guilty prepares or possesses
material that is likely to incite
violence or hatred against a person or
group or person on account of their
protected Char characteristics or any of
those characteristics with a view to the
material being communicated to the
public or a section of the public
whether by himself or himself blah blah
blah prepares or pres such material with
intent to inside violence we get it we
get it you get it being Reckless as to
whether such violence or hatred is is
thereby incited yes they're basically
saying memes if you uh theoretically if
you have Netflix on your phone I'm sorry
Dave Chappelle made race racial jokes
and for
that you're under arrest I mean this is
it this is I
like part of me is actually excited for
this I'll be honest because the line can
only go so far until it goes off the
edge and then there's no line anymore so
they keep pushing and pushing and
pushing and then it's gone and
everyone's just standing around like
okay there's no no rules anymore for
instance like this uh for instance
basically is saying if you have on your
phone a video of Dave Chappelle doing
his his his stand up routine where he
makes fun of Chinese people well that's
it you're going to jail but this is
Netflix this is like
mainstream International top tier comedy
not doesn't matter in New York they just
banned discrimination they signed into
law discrimination on the basis of
weight and height you know this means
insane yeah this means that a 600 lb
morbidly obese person can apply
to be uh you know to work for a
government position or let's say
Starbucks Starbucks and then they let's
say they apply online then the Starbuck
says come in for an interview well that
person can't move of their own power so
they have a crane bring them to the
Starbucks and they can't get in the
building and then they say this is
discrimination based on my weight and
height that I cannot enter the building
for the interview so Starbucks all these
businesses are going to have to tear
they're going have to remodel all their
stores to have double doors to
accommodate the massive and morbidly
obese the line only goes so far until it
falls off the edge when we look back at
architecture it's going to be a crazy
time that's when the double doors come
back I mean this is such a disturbing
way of phrasing it because this idea of
likely to violence or Hast is determined
by the government so what does the
government decide is likely like there
are all kinds of things I don't like
that I'm sure the government is for and
so we know there's automatically a
double standard for for what materials
are okay and what aren't all that really
matters is culture
it you know when we we have the first
amendment in this country you would
still be arrested for obscenity so like
George Carlin for instance this this the
seven words you can't say on TV he gets
arrested for it yeah so even though we
have the First Amendment back then it
didn't matter our culture did not allow
it regardless what the Constitution said
so we talk a lot about the Constitution
and the rights at guarantees but let's
be honest they didn't really guarantee a
whole lot until we started enforcing
them and having the Court's rule to
enshrine these protections and set this
precedent so when we're looking at these
Bans all that really matters the
government will decide whether or not
you go to jail that's it they're
basically the law should say we as the
government can decide to arrest you for
any reason and lock up if we want that's
basically what the law says did you see
that in the in the fat in the no more
discriminating against fat people in New
York the person who bought brought the
uh the bill sha Abu was inspired to
bring the bill because he gained weight
during covid and thought people looked
at him weird after no really no yes
what's his what's his what so he sued
the government on what standing he
didn't sue the government he brought the
bill he's a city councilman I he was
inspired to bring the bill after gaining
weight during the pandemic and noticing
people didn't treat him the same
afterwards and he said it's also about
changing the culture and how we think
about waight when it was um hilarious
yeah when it was uh brought up before
city council and people were arguing in
favor for of it uh and NYU students said
the desks were too small and this was a
reason to not discriminate how much
weight did this guy give gain I need to
know well I was looking for pictures of
him and he looks pretty normal and the
Bill of course was backed by the
National Association to Advance fat
acceptance and the chair of thatou have
that in this country right the chair of
that group said this is such a powerful
moment for anyone who has ever faced
discrimination simply because of the
size of their body someone else said
that they felt pressured to develop an
eating disorder and so this was a reason
to bring the is that the same thing as
dieting I don't have any idea didn't New
York pass a law or or attempt to pass
law like I don't know probably seven or
eight years ago Banning like certain
size beverages like you couldn't get
that was Bloomberg yeah more Super how
we go how did we go from that to now
where we're at with this that's just a
the soda company Sue to be like no
that's discrimination against the size
of our cups you can't do that here well
and also you had Michelle Obama was very
like pro-fitness and now isn't she just
ablest well I mean the Pro Fitness was
like giving kids like high fructose like
just loaded down like grape sodas and
stuff well drinks uh juice that was
loaded with sugar I mean it was it was
it was pretty awful yeah the funny thing
too is Eric Adams who backed this bill
about you know no discriminating against
fat people he's vegan and he he pushed a
plant ba based diet in New York City
schools for Fridays all the there's no
like meat in Fridays and my son would be
like cuz we used to live in Brooklyn and
my son would be like oh it's Friday it's
going to be terrible lunch today so no
meat in school on Fridays yeah it was
like a it was a vegan thing Eric Adams
was pushing a plant-based diet Friday
school we did that right I'm like is
this a Catholic thing no it wasn't it
was an Eric Adams thing for a while they
were pushing a lot of P places pushed
meatless Mondays because they're saying
if you eat less meat it's good for the
environment whatever else but Eric Adams
is like sort of an evangelist uh he's a
super vegan evangelist evangelist diabet
he he had some very serious health
concern was like this Chang he wrote a
whole book about how he lost 35 entire
pound 3 well but he shouldn't brag about
that he had an meting disorder it's
different he clearly had problem he's
got his plate pretty full right now Eric
Adams now the the boomerang of his bill
that they used to get go after Donald
Trump they it literally boomeranged on
the very last day I think it was came
back at him and I mean that guy's Just5
million on that they're investigating
him over uh you know allegations he took
bad money from Turkey the thing about
the turkey though is he was heading down
to
to give Biden what for on immigration
and he literally had to turn that asella
around and head back to New York because
his campaign person her home was raided
by the FBI you know I I don't think that
that was a coincidence Eric Adams who is
both has angered the Biden
Administration by saying we need help
and angered every a burrow around him by
busing migrants to them right yeah well
he he the most most unpopular mayor in
America I don't know how he couldn't be
he really pushing veganism and
everything I want I want to go back to
this I want to talk about Tommy Robinson
we have this from Sky News Tommy
Robinson charged after arrest at
anti-Semitism March The 40-Year-Old and
I love how they do this whose real name
is Steven yaxley Lennon was arrested in
lond London on Sunday I don't know why
it's relevant but they do that a lot and
I think they do it because they're
attacking him they're attacking his
family in one of the videos from the
protest the cops demand his address and
he gets pissed and he's like with all of
these cameras and all these people
standing around me you think I'm going
to give you my address put my family in
danger here's the news activist Tommy
Robinson has been charged after ending
Sunday's March against anti-Semitism in
London The 40-Year-Old former leader of
the far right English Defense League
they say was arrested at the event for
failing to comply with a direction to
disperse let's just be clear your money
and get out I mean what if he was just
like can I take my breakfast to go I bet
they still would have said no organizers
had warned uh warned him he would not be
welcome at the March held in central
London after he signal attention to his
intention to attend in an update on
Monday the Metropolitan Police said
Steven Lennon of bedfordshire has been
charged with failing to comply with a
section 35 Direction excluding a person
from an area he has been bailed to uh to
appear at Westminster magistrates court
on 22nd January the Met said he told
officers he was at the march in his
capacity as a journalist 6,000 people
took part in the event this is the state
of the UK right now that if you are an
activist or a media personality they
will just straight kick you out they
will arrest you for your speech they
will lie they will make up reasons to
shut you down there are so many stories
about what a Speaker's Corner the famous
place where people would stand and speak
now now they all get arrested M only
acceptable government opinions and the
worst thing is look at how the police
behave I got to be honest I I watch this
and I'm like I totally understand the
founding fathers MH I will never forget
the uh video of the police going in and
and raiding the house and and pulling
out the autistic girl did you guys see
that the teenage girl that like called
like somebody a lesbian not even do that
she didn't even do that she basically
said I think she's like Grand her
grandmother is a lesbian and and like
this girl I mean she had I think she
said they said she had scoliosis and
they're dragging her out this teenage
girl and cops her in there like can you
imagine what it must be like to be the
cop that was called a lesbian and just
like sit there like that's evil to look
at this girl that you're saying she's
autistic and you're just sitting there
like yeah I got
you implying something bad she's like oh
she's like Grand like it does that have
to be negative does that I mean there's
a million different words she could have
used that would have been far more
inappropriate but like like at if we use
a offense that's the point the police
said by saying it it was a hate offense
but again does that imply she hates her
grandmother and then it was a hate
offense she really her grandmother the
government is allowed to say whether
you'll be arrested and for whatever
reason yeah and that's it and that
happened to time it's funny cuz we're
talking just a moment ago about Ireland
wanting to pass this law where if you
possess things that may site that means
they're going to walk up to you and say
give me your phone and they're going to
they're going to open Twitter and
they're going to see a picture on
Twitter like oh this is on your phone
and they're going to say something like
when I inspected the defendant's phone I
saw images of racist content that I
believe were on his device and then you
can argue in court I was he pulled up
Twitter and he was looking through posts
and someone retweeted something I had no
control over it they're going to be like
so you admit it you had it on your phone
they are just going to decide in in was
it was the UK where they arrested this
woman yeah it was the it was met police
yeah is just like Kafka it's I mean it's
just like the trial well they tried to
do that won kka reference tonight it's
just I will give you more if you want
yeah that's my favorite part of me being
on the show The the thing about in in
the trial so this guy K he gets home and
there's uh you know police rummaging
around in his room and uh taking his
stuff and searching his stuff and mostly
what ends up happening is he's really
really ashamed he gets arrested people
are looking at him nobody will tell him
what he did wrong you know he can never
get a reasonable answer of what he did
wrong and finally he just gets the
runaround by the courts and everything
and eventually they just kill him in the
street and he's
grateful well the the uh the Harrison
Floyd the Trump case in Fulton County
when they tried to revoke his bond they
did the same thing they were reading
tweets that Harrison Floyd put up and
they would go Fanny Willis would go and
actually read the responses and be like
see look what this incited and it's like
just some mirando with like three
followers that said like oh probably her
that's what I'm saying like at that
point if that's going to be admissible
to to try and revoke somebody's Bond and
put him in a prison where 12 people or
whatever it is have died there in the
last you know year and a half four
people one guy died of bed bug bites if
you're going to revoke somebody's Bond
because of what other people are saying
on Twitter in response to what you say
so now not only do you have to censor
yourself but you have to think about how
others are going to react to what you
say that's crazy well that's the that's
the soldier nson right that's the gulag
archipelago is you get arrested they
don't tell you what you did wrong they
don't tell you why you're there they get
you to say stuff maybe mentioning past
colleagues then past colleagues get
Dragged In arrested not told what they
did wrong and it's really just because
you're Associated that happened all
through you know that whole period and
behind the Iron Curtain it's insane I
think it happens here too we just and
now it's happening here and well cuz we
don't I think part of what's going on is
we just don't believe that this can
happen in America it's shocking to
believe that this can happen in America
it's shocking to believe that you know
our rights can just be trampled like
this we don't believe that it's possible
and I think that that is a little bit of
a naive and I think that is an
overconfidence in our position um and
it's getting in our way of seeing what's
being done to to our country I think
we're winning though right I can't speak
for the UK or for Ireland but I do see
you know in Holland gear Wilder's party
wins and they're they're saying you know
big things coming Javier Malay wins in
Argentina and he has vowed to uh he said
it is non-negotiable they're shutting
down the central bank that is crazy you
know what's funny is whenever I mention
that to people I'm like oh did you see
that the uh new Argentinian president
put out a statement saying the closure
of the central bank is
non-negotiable everybody
says in a manner of speaking they fear
for his well-being yeah well they
probably should James Lindsay was
posting about that he was like and soon
there will be major crises in Argentina
that were just unforeseen yeah how could
this happen but anyway my point is I
think we're winning right especially
when it as it pertains to speech uh
Danny poar made the point last week I
think it was last week where he's like
as soon as Elon bought Twitter everybody
went men aren't women it's like
everybody was finally allowed to say it
and everyone just went off like that was
awesome but isn't it absolutely insane
to look back and be like did you know
that on one of the major social media
platforms you were not allowed owed to
say men aren't women you would be banned
like Megan Murphy was so that being said
we had some pretty dark and creepy days
but we're we're we're clawing back I
think we we've been winning that doesn't
mean we have the majority it doesn't
mean we're going to win it means we have
been consistently gaining ground you've
got uh the daily wide part of the
trailer for that new movie they're doing
lady Ballers it looks hilarious I can't
wait to see it it's out on Friday and uh
it's it's it's a comedy movie about men
who decide to identify as women to play
on a b play on a bunch of sporting teams
and win a bunch of money and it's it's
funny so uh uh I just think with things
like this the culture is being clawed
back I'll also do a shout out we did the
culture War podcast pre-recorded went up
last Friday with Richie Jackson a
professional skateboarder and I'm
getting messages from tons of pro
skateboarders who are like we agree
right the the the woke people who are
coming into these sporting events who
are coming into to video games they
don't know about the culture they don't
care about the culture they actually
actively despise the culture of various
Industries they want to destroy it and
now they're losing more people are
speaking up more people are saying dude
I just don't care I want to just read my
comic books I just want to play video
games I just want to escape think it's
funny that during gamergate the meme was
we just wanted to play video games and
now what I hear from skateboarders as
wokeness is causing problems in
skateboarding it's dude we just want to
skate so when more and more people start
speaking up I just see I think we're
winning you look at Joe Biden's failure
you look how bad he's doing I think
we're winning so I'm having a good time
you know it's it's it's a long road
ahead of us 2024 is going to be wild AF
but it is what it is yeah I think people
are frustrated because it doesn't this
idea of like oh we'll let you live how
you want to live and everything will be
okay has obviously not turned out to be
the other side thought they want to be
the dominant culture in every sphere
they enter and if you have something you
love like skateboarding or whatever
Niche culture you're into to know that
ultimately you're going to have to
dismantle it to accommodate this major
Theology of you know wokeness and
whatever else it's sort of you either
need to decide to protect it or you're
going to lose it and I think we're
seeing this replicated in culture in
geopolitics everywhere right now it's
sort of a make or break moment if you
will it is could we be at an inflection
point possibly potentially isn't that
what we keep hearing from Joe Biden that
we're in an inflection point I can't
believe you can hopefully it inflects
hopefully it inflections him right out
of it yeah nothing matter for him he he
can't run he can't he can't be the Nom
barely walk I mean come on the stairs
are his mortal enemy the most likely
scenario is at the the convention when
when is when is the convention is going
to be in May right I think it's in May
we're talking five months six months the
audition the audition is on Thursday the
audition is on Thursday it's to santis
new when and I hate saying this because
I'm a where are they doing it I don't
know where but Hannity's hosting it
moderating it maybe uh I I mean DeSantis
is an awful awful debater he just he has
no personality uh I mean he's getting
smeared with this with the uh the high
heels and you know whatever he's doing I
mean look he did a pretty good job in
Florida overall I mean we did have
lockdowns during covid it wasn't you
know what everybody said my wife was out
of work for like seven or eight months
where she wasn't allowed to work kind of
let the counties deal with it on their
own but as much as I this pains me to
say Nome is a I mean he's like a
charismatic dude that is going to Suave
his way through this debate and to
santis is just going to be stumbling all
over himself I I I think this is the
audition and Nome comes out looking like
a I mean just a polished turd to be
honest with you but yeah but but it
means the only thing they can do is
decree him the nominee there there will
not be a primary he's not going to be on
the ballot people aren't going to vote
for him the convention is going to
happen they're going to say all in favor
of just having Gavin Newsome be the
nominee I and then everyone's going to
be like I didn't vote for this guy MH
but but what I'm saying terrible and
he's done terrible things to California
absolutely but what I'm saying is this
debate with the santis is going to be
that kind of put his like look
everybody's talking about it I mean V
said in in the last debate just tell us
who your candidate going to be it's to
formally introduce the idea that he is
he is the air parent put on
that I really think the establishment
wanted it to be Ronda santz versus Nome
the the powerful donor class were
getting way behind Des santis but these
people
are bad at what they do that's just
really it and isn't it crazy how long
it's been since 2015 when Donald Trump
announces it was it 25 what what day was
it it was in 2015 Trump announces his
running it comes down the one of his
grandchildren's birthday remember Don
junr said that when he see look it up
yeah and so it's it's been almost 10
years it's been eight years it's going
to be it's we're going in 2024 it's
going to be almost a decade since that
happened that's wild yep June 16th 2015
yeah June
and I I can't I can't for the life of me
figure out like whoever advised Ronda
santis it was a good idea to run in 2024
against Donald Trump I mean Donald Trump
is he is a once in a lifetime
personality period but people didn't
people weren't sure if he had the steam
if it was still there he had the steam
but his announcement I mean Trump trump
is really interesting he is definitely
the center of everything right now but I
remember his announcement at marago
feeling a little bit lackluster there
were a couple months and then his town
hall was just incredible I mean him
pulling out the notes he was so engaged
with the CL crowd there was a reason CNN
was so angry about that town hall but
there was a moment I think we have to
acknowledge there was a moment where
people were like does he have it he had
bad advisers last time and I think
you're right Des santis got bad advice
but there was a reason they were able to
sell it to him because he had a bright
future ahead of him although he's termin
his Governor right it's so bad I almost
think it's an OP I I know I hate saying
that I I almost think it's an OP like
all the donors that flock to the santis
all right you've got your neocons you've
got Con in you know whatever you want to
call it and you know I I don't know I
that's the only explanation I can think
of that makes sense my conspiracy theory
is that everybody was saying Trump Dan
santis it was an unbeatable ticket
people who hated Trump would be willing
to vote because santis is like a good
he's a good Governor he did a good job
and uh so the powers that be say
planning ahead how do we beat a trump
dis it's not just Trump right Trump
Pence Trump tried to find that balancing
factor of the stagi traditional
politician who's he going to find they
said it's going to be disantis and this
dude's pulling through the roof he's
getting massive votes he's he's turned
Florida into a solid red State we it's
going to be Trump des santis and we will
lose no matter what we do no matter who
we swaps it and Des Sanders goes wow I
can be president and they're like yeah
you'll you'll lead the Great American
why they why they attack people so
relentlessly for no reason and I'm like
this was the point make it impossible
for Trump supporters to get behind the
santis so now you send your PR team to
attack anybody who supports Trump so
that they will never be a possibility of
a trumpus ticket and now who's Trump
goingon to have for VP Tucker that also
I think may be unbeatable as well I
think that would be unbeatable that
would be really pretty outstanding TR
for Tucker like Tucker could still do
his show because the VP doesn't really
do anything and uh Trump mentioned
Tucker would be great and then was seen
like a few days later with tuck ER at
Madison Square Garden that was awesome I
loved that see I think we're winning I'm
having a good time what you how you guys
doing I'm loving it yeah right I'm I'm
loving I'm I'm just waiting on all these
boomerangs to come back I mean
everything that they're doing right now
is going to come back on them the the
classified documents case Joe Biden did
that we're now we're expecting Robert
her's report to come out and say oh you
know Joe Biden had tons of classified
documents but we don't think he should
be indicted for it we it's okay when he
does it should indicted for it they
don't think it should be anything at all
there was actually emails revealed that
showed the National Archives said hey
just go get those documents don't say
anything about it be super discreet
about this and then with Trump they drag
in the FBI they alert Secret Service you
know Trump's out of the building they
swarm in it's just insane how he's been
treated in all of these cases you and I
were talking before the show about
what's going on in the Jan 6th case and
how Trump's attorneys recently filed a
motion what was it and the motion was
like to reveal all the FBI agents that
were in in the
or feds feds feds anybody who was
associated with the doj in the capital
near the capital who was part of that
whole thing and I think that's really
going to show what was happening then
yeah I think so you know I think it's
going to reveal that there were feds in
sighting at January 6 like we've thought
all along there's a lot of interesting
stuff going on with that I mean he's got
a motion to reveal all the or to uh to
to stop from the destruction of
classified documents that reveal R
foreign interference in the 2016 and
2020 election I mean that is huge
they're trying to destroy those
documents that I I I got to I can read
the uh the motion directly but it's it's
along those lines but basically it's
acknowledging that hey there's
classified documents relating to foreign
interference in the 2020 and 2016
election I mean you can't possibly think
that you know in in 2018 he writes uh
executive order
13848 which is you know stopping foreign
interference you know giving an an out
for them to seize whatever they need to
you can't possibly think that he watched
this and and nothing came about from it
I you know I don't know I I I think he
was well aware in 2020 and he just had
to he just had to say screw it we're
going forward if I if if Trump would
have turned around in 2020 and and if he
does have foreign interference if he
would have put that out then I mean it
would have been tyranny authoritarian
Hitler like he's just trying to stay a
Banana Republic like they would have
thrown everything they can at him and so
he just said you know what screw it
let's go to 2024 I'll win in 2024
they'll come after me I didn't think it
would be like this but I don't know the
boomerang's coming back yeah I I hope it
does I hope it does that'll be it's sort
of fun to watch sort of fun to watch
from like being far away from everything
too you know the way I describe it is if
we're if we're watching a football game
I'm not saying we're past the 50 yard
line heading towards the end zone we
could be at the 30 yard line but we've
been gaining yards is the point we we've
been gradually making progress after a
uh wonderful and masterfully performed
interception and now uh we're moving in
the other direction I don't anything
about put football so spare me no I
thought that was pretty good I also
don't know anything about football I
don't know and so we're both two people
completely clus about football and
people listening are like oh they're so
wrong about no they think we're right
they think we're good at this uh we're
head their Red Zone baby we're going to
score the goals and all the stuff no I I
think you're right and I think that
makes the American people hopeful I
think that's what you have to pay
attention to is that people are engaged
and are frustrated and are willing to do
something about in a way I feel like
they haven't been in a really long time
they weren't even in 2020 and that that
is too bad we sort of missed the mark on
that one but now they are suffering the
consequences of their inaction and
hopefully they're motivated to do
something just to be clear it says uh
the motion is a notice excuse me notice
and objection to unauthorized deletions
of classified information and it says
president Trump will offer classified
information at trial relating to foreign
interference activities that impeded the
2016 and 2020 elections as well as
efforts by Administrations to combat
those activities president Trump will
also present classified information
relating to the biased and politicized
nature of the intelligence assessments
that he and others rejected during the
events in question fascinating and
apparently I guess they were trying to
destroy that I feel like the discovery
in the Trump Cas is really there's going
to be so much and that's why they're
they're slapping these gag orders on so
that nobody can talk about what's in the
evidence yeah even though that should be
made very available to the American
people I don't think the judges will
give Fair Discovery processes I think
Canon is Canon seems to be doing a
pretty good job in the uh the Florida
seized documents case as we've been
calling it um and she was a I think she
was a trump appointee and she was like
no doj we can't have this underway in
December you lunatics it's millions of
pages of documents so she's pushed that
back she has like a normal trial
schedule for that one so we'll see how
that goes I think New York's going to be
a bit different I think Georgia's going
to be very different we were talking
about this before the show all the
people pleading guilty that's what
they're going for they're going for
public record you mentioned Trump is
appealing in Colorado despite the fact
that he won because the courts ruled
that he did wage Insurrection and this
is the plan you don't get Trump knocked
off the primaries you get him knocked
off the general so one by one each state
is an opportunity to get precedence at
least in these states that Trump did
wage Insurrection and then they can say
well look at this look at this I don't
know if that'll fly at the state level
but at the federal level you see one of
the questions I think it was Minnesota
was the states don't have the right to
determine eligibility only the federal
government therefore this lawsuit must
be Federal you get a bunch of states to
rule Trump waged Insurrection then they
suit the federal government level and
say these states have determined Trump
did wage Insurrection therefore he
should be removed well I mean there use
that yeah there's a question of whether
the 14th Amendment even applies to the
president it doesn't well so I I I know
I know cash Patel says that it does and
and I trust his his legal opinion I just
he said it does it does like that it it
would no he said I thought he said the
14th Amendment it doesn't mention the
Office of the President you you said
says it things it does no oh excuse me
I'm sorry I'm sorry I apologize it
doesn't right it does say I think it
says the Executive offices it says
officer of the United States yeah so
wasn't it trying to just keep I mean it
was basically trying to keep Jefferson
Davies and all those guys off the ballot
exactly exactly so but but he hasn't
been he hasn't been charged with it he
hasn't been charged with Insurrection s
not in any of the cases not in a single
one so you think that a 6 to3 Supreme
Court is going to rule to keep him off
the ballot if if it gets to the I mean I
I don't see that happening no I see sing
Single State deciding that Trump isn't
eligible due to these rulings therefore
and they just remove him and then Trump
sues but by the time it's rectified
there's no ballot with his name on it
they they so they don't say anything
they just start printing ballots then
when everyone finds out on Election Day
or during early early voting that there
is no Trump's name isn't on it Trump SU
within a couple days get his emergency
injunction too late 3 or 4 days they
gain an advantage where Trump's not on
the ballot and theoretically and all the
mail inot sorry go out with no Trump on
the ballot well the ballots have to be
printed I think 90 days they have to be
public 90 days before the election I
believe well hopefully so if that's the
case I mean you you're going to have a
lot of I mean I'll tell you right now
that is the quickest way but 90 days in
which state is that every state does
that I think that's well no that's a
good point it's yeah Most states that
I've seen have 90day safe harbors for
everything ically if it comes out that
the feds were the ones who ultimately
incited January 6 then Trump probably
did not partake in Insurrection Trump
wasn't even done speaking Yeah he wasn't
even I was there he wasn't even done
speaking but you wouldn't prosecute the
feds who did incite the Insurrection
right like would the FBI director would
any of these agency heads be the ones to
take the fall for inciting Insurrection
probably not no here's yeah Republicans
need to start making criminal referrals
to the to the capital police because it
will put Meritt Garland in an impossible
situation they say here's a video of a
police officer letting the J in the
building he should be arrested and
charged now what's going to happen the
Democrats are going to say no we're not
charging this cop Democrats don't like
cops Democrats want Cops criminally
charged for their for you know and held
quote unquote accountable if it's true
so I I don't think a single cop will get
actually charged or arrested but put
them in the decision dilemma either you
arrest the cops and stand by what you
think is an Insurrection or you refuse
to arrest the cops who opened the door
and let them in let the American people
see you do that and it's going to make
all the American American people who
have ever questioned January 6 be like
hey wait a minute see this video the
Republicans are calling out video of
cops letting people in the building and
the Democrat mer Garland will not arrest
these guys something doesn't add up
right I think that's important to to
note because if they did if if they're
going to imply all the cops were in on
it then there's intense government
corruption but if they're saying no the
cops are fine I think every American
citizen who's affected by this who's
thought about this last year will
obviously see how how corrupt this
system is it creates a big problem for
them yeah and I think that no no no
Democrat activist is going to defend a
cup right and I think that's the
question they will US capital police not
because because they they fought against
the Insurrection they're the sold them
they sold them as hero maybe Adam Chef
and and and like these these neolibs but
you are not going to get the average
like 30-year-old Democrat to get behind
cops well and this comes up to the Biden
administration's major problem which is
that they have to uh to uh appease their
typical donor class and also the young
progressives that are coming up within
their party and there's a huge division
between them and also the point is we're
not talking about the that that who's
that guy who went on CNN over and over
again I was just about to say we're
talking about we're not talking about
phenone we're talking about videos of
cops opening the door and the
Republicans saying look a cop was in on
it the whole time and let him in arrest
him mer where you at arrest him what
what neolib is going to answer to that
they're going to ignore it to the best
of their abilities because if the if the
argument is the capital police fought an
Insurrection like oof well if they make
a single arrest all the narrative starts
becoming wow there were Capital police
in on the Insurrection the whole time
they can't do that that's a good point
it creates a very serious dilemma for
Democrats they'll have to desperately
ignore the story and if the Republicans
make this is the thing Republicans need
to learn how to do okay a reporter walks
up to you with with a camera and they or
they have you on your show CNN says will
you come on and I always say don't do
these interviews but yeah yeah you get
Matt Gates you go on CNN and then Matt
Gates when they say what's this
immigration plan well we just uh uh uh
filed a criminal referral to police
officers who are seen on camera and
newly released evidence opening the door
for the Riders on January 6 we want them
arrested and you see that on CN and then
they're going to be like well we didn't
ask you that and be like I know I just
wanted to make sure all the CNN viewers
knew that we're going after the cops who
aided the people on January 6 and we're
calling on our Democrat counterparts to
demand Meritt Garland file the arrest
warrants for these police officers in
the Capitol Police and they're going to
go uhoh what do we do start sacrificing
you know what happens then if the
capital police feel that they have no
political allies every man for himself
all of a sudden these these phenone
types are going to be like ain't
nobody's coming to save me you if if you
are political fod that's it no one's got
your back Democrats certainly won't have
your back I think that's the play well
where are Republicans to call in uh you
know yogan Ona Pitman I I've heard Terk
Johnson I've had him on my show uh twice
now and uh he was a 22-year he he has
more experience with the US capital
police than than chief's son and yogan
on Pitman he was 22 years there his wife
Capital police officer and he's been
saying call her in she was the person
that had all the Intel she was the one
that prevented that Intel from going up
the chain and and and now she's failing
upwards at Berkeley as a you know a
police chief out there making four times
whatever she was making they also they
kept her on the payroll or they they
gave her temporary leave so that she
could retire from the US capital police
and get her benefits unpaid leave
administrative leave whatever while she
was collecting a paycheck at the get her
in there what we we got we got the house
what are you guys doing come on let's uh
let's jump to the story my friends from
the New York Post I'm G to start by
saying this #f free Dereck shovin
railroaded Derk chauvin's foes will stop
at nothing to punish exop as he's nearly
killed in prison yo this dude certainly
does not deserve any of this and it's
very obvious that the government is
sacrificing him for their own protection
because they are evil because they are
evil people we saw this with the ammed
Arbury case as well we're seeing it now
with Derrik chovin he was nearly killed
shortly after his appeal to the Supreme
Court was rejected and it and and I
think the reason is our Supreme Court
people need to understand they're always
like oh we got this great conservative
Supreme Court oh they're cowards dude
Thomas and Alo are based AF and uh
that's fantastic but the rest of them
are cowards who are terrified of
actually doing anything think of you
know it's just I'm sorry man American
culture is in shambles it's in Decay we
have a generation several generations
with too many spineless spineless
leaders and it's sad
but it is what it is and so this is the
story now chovin appeals Supreme Court
they say no shortly after he's nearly
killed listen we can all argue yeah you
shouldn't kneel on a guy's back and neck
to whichever argument you want to make
fine whatever if it was on the neck say
don't kneel on the neck he was trained
to do it he showed up after Floyd was
already on the ground he said in in in
in an interview that they were waiting
for the ambulance to come it didn't come
he could have certainly taken his knee
off the neck the guy who was clearly not
breathing there's a lot of things he did
wrong and for that you get fired you get
involuntary manslaughter which is like
maybe two years probation never be a cop
again the city is forced to pay out a
settlement end the training practice of
kneeling on someone's back or neck
instead they claim this guy is an evil
racist who intentionally murdered a
black man blah blah blah all that stuff
federally indict him lock him up and
throw away the key and then someone
tries to kill him if this is allowed to
stand like there's no no justice in this
country okay because you can argue let's
say you're you're the most Fringe far
leftist person if you would argue and
and many of them are laughing that he
was attacked saying well that's what you
get I'm like okay you're fascists and
you are evil you cannot like the guy you
can have the opinion he's an evil man
who did wrong and still even if you do
understand that proper Justice requires
he not die being murdered in prison or
imprisoned for the rest of his life in
multiple charges yeah and the argument
for a while was if he was in federal PR
prison he's safer right the idea and
this was in the Amed Opera case this the
father son do were sent to State Prison
after they asked they got convicted on
Federal and State charges they asked to
be sent to sent to federal prison for
their own safety and they were denied
they were sent to State Prison because
there they want ultimately I think a lot
of progressive uh AGS in this country
really want to see a bloody end for
these people and that's horrible and sad
and the judge in uh chauvin's case was
like well if he's going to go to Federal
Pres put him somewhere his family can
see him right and he's their families
between Iowa and Minnesota and they're
like no Arizona we'll see you later and
now they're not giving the family
information about his status they're
learning about it as the news updates
which is crazy well that's what his mom
said and then the judge also had come
out and said that they were surprised
that chovin was transferred to Arizona
and that it was done without their
awareness or knowledge of it but the the
the Bureau of Prisons doesn't have to
take a judge's recommendation uh which
is I mean maybe that's good maybe that's
bad in this case I think it's pretty
awful because did you guys see fall of
Minneapolis did you guys watch that no
what is it it's this uh documentary it
was a crowdsource documentary about this
case and everything that happened in the
riots after George Floyd and what what
went down it's actually pretty
interesting but they talk to um the
other cops in the case and all of them
are like no that we we did what our
training was you know the autopsy um uh
showed that there were drug drugs that
it was like most likely an overdose oh
this this is the one where they
mentioned the FBI interfere with the uh
medical examiner report right and that
the body cam footage wasn't released for
months which we knew at the time because
that was like everyone kept waiting for
the body cam footage to come out and it
never did and then it was just months
and months later after the government
had full control of the narrative right
and the implication was like a gang of
white cops who had you know assaulted it
was it was like an Asian guy there was a
black guy you know it was like the
makeup of the city was in this little
unit locked up the dude who was simply
holding back a crowd mhm that's crazy
like that that guy had no idea what was
even going on he was a guy everyone stay
back stay back and so now he's going to
jail for for a long time well nothing
nothing ever is going to happen
unfortunately positive for for Chavin
nothing is going to happen positive if
it does you'll have you'll have that
summer of love all over again so may
maybe something does happen actually
actually maybe something does happen and
that's what the the left is going to use
to push the p monium in the summer of
2024 just before the although Trum
pardon
him Trump should par he can't pardon him
in Minneapolis he he can par the federal
charges yeah the federal Cas so when
Trump's president he can issue a pardon
do you think we're going to see riots
this summer yes what are they going to
be over over immigration immigration
riots no race uh every four years you
know on Election years so uh 2020 Summer
can you can you believe it it's been
over 3 years I cannot even believe wild
right when the sum The Summer of Love I
love that that's what it's called who
who was it who said that it was Jenny
derkin it was the mayor of Seattle
Summer of Love what a turd she is just
the
worst she also said that the uh Chaz the
CH the Seattle autonomous Zone she also
said it was like a big block party yeah
with people being killed with with
killing black teenagers 14-year-olds in
2020 who weren't paying attention will
be voting next year yeah wow and they're
voting for Trump apparently Trump's up
46 to uh what is it he's up he's up four
points I think against Biden according
to NBC News in the youth vote let's
break that down for a second because I I
was looking at this the other day so
Trump is up in the 18 to 34 vote I think
he's up right I think he's okay he's up
uh he's getting right now I think they
he's it's a what what how do they
describe it NBC news said Biden minus
four that's what they said okay well so
the the overall poll like the the total
of the poll I think had Trump winning by
like four points if you go through the
individual categories I think the black
vote was around 24% which is insane he
got 12% in NBC News I I'm talking about
yeah let me let's pull it up I have
screenshots of it cuz I was arguing this
with somebody but uh Trump was had about
20 I think it was 24% of the black vote
which is awesome because I think he got
12% in 2020 he was uh plus six away from
or he was six points away from Biden in
the Hispanic vote I think it was like 42
to 48 M or something like that he lost
the Hispanic vote by 32 points points in
2020 so Trump is up 12 points on the on
the black vote he's pulled within he's
he's cut 26 points on the Hispanic vote
he's winning the 18-34 vote and the
overall poll only had him winning by
like three points or four points or
something like that are you insane like
if if you tell any Republican those
numbers for a republican candidate and
you don't tell them it's Donald Trump
they're like oh my that's a that's a
Ronald Reagan 19 uh 1980 Landslide I
mean it's it's he wins all 50 states he
takes min too that would be great are
there any they saying Trump lost well so
here's a couple of questions he wasn't
any demographic sorry go if the election
is between a generic Republican and Joe
Biden it's 48 points for the Republican
and 37 for Biden if it's Trump versus
any other Democratic candidate it's 46
for the Democrat and 40 for Trump and I
don't know if they asked the inverse
question I think it's just those too
because I'd be interested if it was
uh if it's uh Joe Biden versus Trump but
it's probably somewhere in the poll but
that right there is interesting enough
but anyway continue what was your
question oh I'm always curious to see
like it's great that he's gaining I'm
also curious to see where there any are
any potential losses right or is it just
Joe Biden who's losing supporters I mean
this was a poll a couple months ago we
saw a swing state poll that had of like
what was it six swing States and it had
Trump up in Georgia Pennsyvania Arizona
and down in
Wisconsin which was was like the one
state that Biden one of the Swing States
and I'm missing one in my Michigan yeah
I'm missing Michigan that's right and
you had Trump up in Michigan as well
yeah so and and he's winning Nevada too
he's I think he's up like I think he's
up like six or seven points in Nevada as
well which is and Wisconsin was the
whitest state of the states surveyed so
that was sort of interesting as well
yeah I mean so so I think I I think I
think they're saying uh right now they
got Trump up two points against Biden is
that the same one that has those same
cuz I I know the numbers on the
demographics are spoton because I I I
have a photographic memory when it comes
to that so um does it have the breakdown
by the black vote the 18 to 34 that's
what I'm looking for that was that was
the the generic right now they're saying
Trump's up to and so real real CL
politics is showing Trump's averaging
2.6 points above Joe Biden a lot can
happen in a year a lot can
happen keep try and find the uh
breakdown by race if they have it I
don't know a lot of this is just the
general questions I know Ras M had a
poll in the beginning of October cuz I I
literally bought their Platinum package
just to be able to read this poll they
had Trump winning 51% of the black vote
yeah I S I remember that the number of
random subscriptions I have and then
it's like I don't even remember how I
subscribed I have no idea how to cancel
it hey look at this you or someone else
in your household owns a gun of any kind
52 applies 43 does not apply that's
interesting gun rights baby people in
this country want to be able to own
guns yeah Democrats trying to take them
away it's going to piss them off and
they don't like Joe Biden I mean Joe
Biden is intensely unpopular poll show
this over and over again the fact that
there was a majority of Democrats were
like no he's too old to be president
that does not vote well for a reelection
campaign he only gets older yeah the the
one concern that I would have about um
you know declaring a trump Victory
prematurely would be uh that I think
Gavin Nome would be a wild card and I
don't know what would happen there I
know a lot of people that um you know
that I talk to who are not really
conservative but they're also not really
liberal they really don't like Joe Biden
they also don't like Trump and I think
they would grab at a chance to vote for
somebody they've never heard of who
might have a reasona blish smile like
Gavin Nome I think Pete they had to have
heard of Gavin new though I mean
especially after Frisco you know you
don't hear of them the same way and if
you're not that engaged in politics
you'd know like oh Gavin Nome he's the
he's the governor of California and
California's fine it's he had one big
viral moment when he was doing his um
acceptance speech or his like inaugural
address and his I remember it went viral
because PE I think a lot of the country
didn't really know him and his son like
came up on stage people were like how
funny how cute this young you know tall
governor and this you know adorable
child and he's he's a dad and a
politician and for Californians they're
like no we don't like that guy and
people neighboring know it but the
average American who's just in the
midwest who doesn't care about
California that much just saw it as this
like oh he's the guy with the kids right
and they forgot all about French Laundry
right and how he was totally um pushing
covid mandates on everybody but doing
whatever he pleased himself including
sending his kids to private schools that
were not closed during the pandemic MH i
w with with everything that that new
some that you hear about California Prop
47 and all the crime that's running
rampant there coming out and saying oh
yeah yeah g ping is coming over here so
we we just moved all the homeless people
we can't do it for you guys but we did
it for him and he said like at the time
he was like oh you've been hearing
rumors that we did this because the
pretty people are coming to town and we
did that is why fancy people not pretty
people they're not pretty but fancy yeah
and he confirmed that that was in fact
true and it was a nice little chuckle oh
look he's telling the truth how about
that what a guy didn't he like delay
vaccinating his kids even though every
other kid all the other students in
California there was also didn't wear a
mask yeah didn't he like get vaccinated
and like dis hair you know remember
remember that he got vaccinated and then
like three weeks he disappears and
they're like oh he's at a a wedding and
they take like this Sky View and they're
like that's him the back of his head in
the third row and everybody was like
thinking he had G and bar syndrome or
whatever yeah but it's also just like
Gavin n being like I'm going on vacation
you know what for three weeks as do
whatever he
wants that he's he's a dude who decreed
masks and then has seen quite literally
fanc restaurant not wearing masks he did
not care but uh I want to jump to this
we got questions about Joe Biden whether
or not he's going to be out and Trump's
going to win and so we're wondering what
could happen here's a story from Zero
Hedge 64 US Bank branches filed to shut
down in a single week are you affected
uh listen it may not be my bank that
shut down I'm not saying you know maybe
uh your bank shut down but regardless of
whether it was your personal Branch yo
you're all affected branches are
shutting down and so the question is why
is it happening well obviously the
economy is pretty Bonkers right now it
it doesn't make sense at all you've got
people who can't afford to eat and
you've got casinos popping up all over
the place I swear the casino thing
really makes me think we're in like the
end of days Chicago just approved
recently a$ 1.6 billion Bal casino on
the river in the city goodness and they
just opened the first Chicago Casino B's
temporary location and I'm like
when they start legalizing gambling
across the board and casinos are popping
up and what does a casino do you just
give money away I mean you you could win
money but come on it's you're paying for
entertainment the simplest form of a
casino is you go there you lose money
you have fun you have drinks you leave
they're popping up all over the place
meaning there's a lot of people with
disposable income at the same time there
are way too many people with no income
at all that can't afford to live and
can't afford to get houses they can't
afford to buy
groceries this it can't make maintain
itself so they're saying one of the
reasons the banks are closing down is
that everyone's just doing digital right
now so they don't need them and I'm like
yeah that's not that's not it like
probably but if the economy was doing
well and the banks were doing well they
would keep their locations open for
marketing purposes and just to have an
available loc location for people who
are just happening to be in the area I
get it is a fair point why keep a bank
branch open if everyone's online anyway
but if you had the money you would
there's not a lot going into opening a
bank branch I guess they can fire a lot
of people I guess in the long run they
save a lot of money I think the real
issue is we have seen what six Banks
entire Banks shut down this year yeah
it's been really a lot of banks it's
been scary and now we're seeing Bank
branches shutting down I'm not going to
sit back while the people in the media
are like this is totally normal and
everyone's fine the stock market will be
great and just keep doing your thing I'm
like nah me personally I don't know I'll
buy some Bitcoin or something maybe get
some property in Argentina yo we were
looking at property in Argentina oh on
the pp it's beautiful there well no all
I know is you can get there we found
like 500 Acres that was only accessible
by raft and it's like four grand and I'm
like that's that seems pretty great I
was in argena good luck getting there
but can you get starlink yes there you
go I was there for a theater conference
in 2003 and it was like this uh this
like compound in the pompus uh it was
really exceptional and Off the Grid and
pretty wacky I recommend
Argentina you know for all those who are
preparing for the apocalypse El Salvador
is sounding pretty good Argentina
especially wow you know I made the joke
I'm like can we elect Javier Malay in
the United States somehow is there like
some Special Rule you bring him him
right now don't be too quick I mean they
still do have 140% inflation when he
pulls off the Central Central uh the
Central Bank down there we'll see what
happens so you're saying wait till it
bottoms out that's and then buy and then
buy I mean I I don't know look I mean
they've been lying about this economy to
the American for so long with mortgage
rates up around almost 8% I mean that's
that's absurd like that I mean we look
at 2008 and what happened with 2008 when
the adjustable rate mortgages started
just going up ever so slightly and all
of a sudden these people couldn't afford
their $250,000 home anymore that was an
$800 payment and now it ballooned to
$1,700 and they're like well that's the
same thing that's happening right now if
right exactly everyone that bought
everyone that bought a home in 2020 is
like probably in the war I would not
want to be in their situation right now
because it's it's cheaper to rent right
now than it is to buy a home but yeah
everyone that bought in 2020 like
they're watching that that interest rate
go up and just hoping if they have like
a variable interest rate yeah yeah I I
don't know how many people are doing
that these days they still do the
variable interest rates I mean that's
appealing right now but I I I don't know
what the adjustable rates are at right
now I just looked at the fixed but cuz
cuz you're cuz you you don't want to go
in at 8% so you're like I'll take 6%
variable yeah and then it goes to 15 and
you're like that's what happens yeah I
wouldn't do that yeah but so many people
would they don't know they don't
understand how it works and they just do
it I would just take like the lowest I
could get buy down for
points well and the Market's great too
like my house right now is worth
significantly more than it was when we
bought it in like
2016 2015 significantly more like to the
point where I'm telling my wife like we
need to sell the home and buy an RV and
just drive around the country for a year
wait till all this sorts itself out and
then when it comes back down we can buy
a home and own it outright and not have
a mortgage payment or anything like that
but you can't buy anything in the
meantime you can't Reby at 8% I
mean I was talking to my mom about this
and she was buying uh you know she's
fine now but she was buying real estate
in like the 80s and 90s and stuff and
she was telling me that her her first
home that she bought it was like you
know 12% and they thought that was
pretty good at the time and that was in
the 80s you know so
% yeah it has changed rather
significantly just our sense of what a
normal interest rate is I'm locked in at
2.75 and I'm staying there nice
congrats I'm not I I if if the economy
gets worse then Trump's
unbeatable yeah Trump Carlson 2024 with
a crumbling economy Banks shutting down
everywhere crime through the roof he's
going to come back out he's going to
give his first rally and he's going to
go for those listening I'm just
shrugging or or a very very very deadly
virus somehow makes its way over here
with a
99.99% uh survival rate and we have to
shut down everything
999 that's deadly 9 survival I don't you
you were right I was trying to make a
joke I don't think that will work again
no it won't that's why they're trying to
get him off the ballot right so the the
real play is going to have to be some
kind of Trumps not eligible one one of
my thoughts is that they the the the
neocon neol establishment when I say
uh is resigned to the fact they're going
to lose and so the play is set Trump up
for massive failure look at Afghanistan
Biden chose to to to destroy Afghanistan
to to I mean this was this was a
deliberate action by the United
States if Trump was in office the
Afghanistan withdrawal would have been
fine would it have been great no that's
ridiculous there's probably bad things
that going to happen but abandoning bam
Air Force Base in the middle of the
night I think it's possible that the
Biden Administration said let's make
Afghanistan the biggest disaster in in
in in you know of Our Generation so that
way we can be like oh no look go when
you withdraw look at all the bad things
that we can't withdraw now oh it'll be
Afghanistan all over again then Syria
then Iran whatever else we're going to
invade the playmate now may be let Trump
fine he's going to win we'll just make
sure that there's landmines every step
he takes and then we'll say you see what
happens when you elect someone like
Donald
Trump maybe I mean I think Trump has
popular support it it will be anybody
who takes office has to unravel Biden's
mess and that will always be an issue um
but I think generally the sentiment is
that no one could be worse than Biden
and even if they were to switch him out
for Gavin Nome it's expensive to live in
California right like I don't want his
economic policies either and so there's
no one on the Democratic bench that they
could suddenly pull up before next year
who's like a Who will win the economic
argument I think Americans are
completely voting based on how what how
much they're paying in gases and how
much they're paying in groceries and
ultimately it has to be a republican the
Republican states are fairing better not
great but a lot of them are better off
and Trump has the popular confidence
vote I mean people believe Trump can
make a difference what what it will
actually look like that obviously makes
us nervous but it can't be a Democrat
Democrat states and cities are failing
for this mhm yeah that's true wh who
could possi oh she is so terrible oh
she's terrible but Democrats don't have
anybody even even Nome can't Spin The N
he can't pitch the story there's no Nome
story Trump's got a character Arc
Trump's got a story Trump's got pois in
Colorado who I know my polus I know but
nobody knows who that is oh yeah I mean
he had his moment with the tread on me
kid right right there is there is no
Democrat that has X Factor not a single
one I know my my co-host on why vote is
literally cringing right now cuz I said
po she's from Colorado and cannot stand
that can't win his own State there's no
way it could be him I think you're right
there's there's no Democrat that that
has it and part of it is because none of
them are good at the economy and that's
what's going to matter this this round I
mean all right fine I'll say it Michelle
Obama nope no you don't think so you
don't think they they would roll her out
maybe maybe but I don't think she has
the story I don't think she can spin the
story what are they going to say Biden
is the OB Administration the reason they
wanted Biden was because they wanted to
be like remember Obama I remember Obama
and now it's bad Michelle Obama's going
to come out and be like we're going to
try Obama again yeah and people are
going to be like I don't know Obama 3.0
maybe maybe I mean that NBC new news
poll if you like the polls maybe you
don't they said any any Democratic
candidate versus Trump wins and so maybe
maybe not r m actually has Biden up in
the polls against Trump surprisingly the
one the one poll in the in the real
clear politics
M well you still don't we're still not
even factoring in that that Biden is
also on top of all the atrociousness
with the economy and you know foreign
policy and everything else he's still
running against RFK Jr and Cornell West
and we're going to get a fourth person
in here somebody from that independent
party ticket is going to you know I know
Mitt Romney said he doesn't want it you
know somebody else is going to get in
there whether it's Joe Manion Joe Manion
well it's going to be I think it's going
to be a split ticket and if they put the
Republican on top that could have
some of the you know establishment
Republicans that are still out there
will rally behind that that could
actually hurt Trump a little bit but uh
I mean the the the RFK Jr thing I think
is going to absolutely Crush uh uh Biden
really no shot people were saying like I
heard a lot of people talking about how
the RFK run would actually hurt Trump
because makes no sense he's an outsider
Trump's an outsider RFK Jr announcing
his campaign on quote indigenous
people's day just excluded every right
leaning moderate every every Centrist
independent they're just all gone and he
teased the Border stuff he was like the
border is a serious issue but then he
wouldn't say and I will build a wall if
he had done something like that then
yeah there might have been people who
are like this is my issue we're going
here I can see the implications but he
is like toying with some of his right
supporters the right supporters are
enthusiastic about him but they
ultimately there was this New Hampshire
poll that was like if if your first
choice doesn't run who would you vote no
one picked RFK they were still picking
Trump and and you know whoever else
first he he has popular support because
he's so radical but ultimately he is
siphoning off votes from the Democrats
interesting well he he's likable and a
lot of Republicans right now know that
he was you know against the vaccine and
that's that's big with them and the
Border like you said but they haven't
really heard him your average everyday
Republican that doesn't listen to the
news all the time hasn't heard his
stance on the climate change hasn't
heard his stance on gun rats uh you know
he's really into abortion too abortion
hasn't heard any of these things so I
mean if if if they could just stop stop
right now and take the P the the
perception that a lot of Republicans
have in terms of RFK Jr and and and have
the vote right now yeah he might take a
little bit I I still think he takes more
from from Biden he might take a little
bit but not much I think it's funny
whenever the leftist media Outlets talk
about Trump's plans for immigration and
the border and they're like he wants to
deport a lot of people he wants to
really cut down on the border he really
wants to do all this stuff he wants to
put people in camps until he can get
them deported and the Republicans are
like sounds good Republicans are like
that's amazing why aren't we doing that
now or like the thing today I saw he
wants to put back into effect the family
separation policy well that was really a
a deterrent for people to not come you
know and Biden is doing family
separation too only families are
separating themselves way before they
get here and then their kids get sold to
human traffickers but when the media
reports like Donald Trump what say
Donald Trump will imprison political
opponents and engage in Mass deportation
what they the headline actually Donald
Trump to enforce law it's like oh okay
NPR was was arguing that abortion is
going to be the big issue either like
this is everything everyone's going want
it to be because it was in the midterms
they say that that had a big impact on
sure and it's the only thing that they
can say to make people hysterical right
see Republicans don't get it they play
everything straight shot no no no you
got to understand the play is for
Republicans to all come out all sit on
like a they should have a big event
where they get a bunch of candidates Pro
sitting at a table and they all just
kind of look at each other and
go so
liberals liberals want to abort their
children we're for that we we we are all
for that uh we agree yes uh liberals
should be allowed to abort all of their
children only registered Democrats
though yeah you uh well not even you say
just just and then they're going to be
like wait what why yeah why are why are
why you saying I'm just the Republicans
need to be like we are in favor of
liberals getting abortions thank you and
have a nice day they can't be I mean
true pro- lifers don't want anybody to
abort their children I I think I do
think it's a huge problem for
conservatives for for the Republican
party that you have a staunch unmovable
faction I I understand the arguments and
I don't disagree I think it's strong to
have morals I'm saying there is a risk
there because they're going to lose a
lot of suburban women that's just the
abortion thing yeah I was playing I was
playing golf on Saturday with a guy and
uh we just got paired up with him I
didn't know him personally beforehand
and uh we first hole we he asked me what
I do I tell him I'm a writer a podcaster
and all that and he says oh I'm I'm a
software engineer and I do you know a
lot of Pol political stuff and uh I'm
very Progressive and I was like oh this
is going to be an interesting round of
golf we never asked we never got into
specific people except AOC and Matt
Gates and the bill that they kind of
co-sponsored together over term limits
and our general consensus by the end of
the match was uh we need to get rid of
the kitchen table topics the abortion
the gun rates and all that stuff is not
going anywhere anytime soon the
abortions down at the states where it
needs to be gun R aren't going any what
what's that disagree on the abortion you
don't think abortion should be at the
states no but continue well anyways the
bottom line is is we both agreed that
that the next Administration whether
it's you know the the president the next
Congress everybody got to get our
together man we got to stop passing
these CRS we got to stop passing the
omnius we got to get term limits in
there absolutely have to have term
limits um like the fact that Diane
Feinstein died in office crazy the fact
that they TMZ is interviewing her and
like uh you know how's it feel to be
back and she's what do you mean I feel
to be back I've been here the whole time
like no you've been gone for fedman I
mean feder's asking a question of a
banker and it's so bad that the banker
at the end is like I don't know you
can't make sense of what he's saying so
I think I think fed's actually recovered
quite a great deal though at this point
I haven't seen him lately his latest
videos are coherent oh and he's and he's
pretty funny I got to be honest so so
what's what's on the on the uh abortion
human rights are a question for the
federal government whether the
Constitutional Constitution applies to
an individual is a question for the
federal government to
answer do do the do do The Unborn have a
have guaranteed rights to life that is
not something the states can decide I I
mean I personally think they do but is
it explicitly in the Constitution so
like the 14th Amendment for
instance uh that the constitution
applies to the people we we went over
this with the end I'm not going to pull
it up again
but do do do babies do do The Unborn
have uh have have god-given
rights yeah so why then would you say
that if you are born the federal
government guarantees your rights but if
you're unborn the federal government
does not guarantee your rights because
the left doesn't see that same way but
they have a different opinion so I'm
with you I'm you're arguing it should
not be a federal question I think if the
federal government is is saying the
Constitution applies to all of its
subjects then I would say oh okay then
The Unborn are humans with human rights
the same as any born person why then
would it be a question for the state to
be allowed to say nah we're they're
determining this person is not a human
you know what I mean because they're
referring the conversations about
abortion aren't about The Unborn Child
they're always about the woman who's
carrying the child right my point is the
federal government needs to answer the
question of whether or not The Unborn
have god-given and and guaranteed rights
I think that makes sense I'm just saying
is the answer yes or no and I you know
when roie Wade was first over turned I
said it probably makes sense the states
can determine it you know I don't know
and then after having several arguments
about it I was like no nah we're we're
going back to this period where some
states determined that some people were
were or were not worthy of full
god-given protected uh rights Peru
recently passed a bill that uh called
the law that recognizes rights of the
conceived giv making sure that The
Unborn have constitutional rights right
like does it can a state right now say
that um we' determine white men are not
human no but they can a white baby is
not human that's what they can say no so
why why give them the power to determine
the the life of the child's value or
their rights but not for someone who's
born if the if if argument is pro-life
then Pro lifers should be saying the
Constitution guarantees the rights of
The Unborn the same as the born but
wouldn't the Constitution then have to
because look and I'm I'm with you on
this I'm with you as a conservative I'm
with you but the left they're making the
argument that it's not a it's not a
person it doesn't have any rights until
it's actually born which I disagree with
strongly but because of that that would
then be I I mean unless unless you get a
ruling from the Supreme Court saying
that yes as soon from the moment of
conception or you know and this was what
roie way was originally supposed to be
from 3 weeks 6 weeks whatever it is it's
a person from that point on until we
have something like that on on the
record on the books in in the federal
you know either statute or in the
Constitution Amendment so I think the
ruling from the Supreme Court should
have been as 14th Amendment says all
persons born or naturalized in United
States and subject to the jurisdiction
thereof are citizens of the United
States and of the state wherein they
reside period next Clause no State shall
make or enforce any law which shall
abridge the Privileges or immunities of
citizens of the United States semicolon
nor shall any state deprive any person
of life liberty or property without due
process of law nor deny to any person
within its jurisdiction the equal
protections of laws is an unborn baby a
person as per the Constitution that
question needs to be answered because if
it does that means no State can deprive
a baby an unborn child of Life L there
is a due process hearing that's a
question that the federal government
needs to answer I do not believe it
should be up to states to decide who is
a person and who isn't I also think it's
kind of shocking that the federal
government could decide a certain group
of people are not persons as well but it
does need to be adjudicated and ruled
upon the question as per the 14th
Amendment are The Unborn persons yes or
no what would you
say B I mean based on the 14th Amendment
generic question are they a person yes
there you go then they can't then
abortions are illegal without due
process Heering to determine the the
rights and and the the justification for
abortion end of story no exceptions none
whatsoever I am not pro-life right cuz I
think there's a lot of I I think the
issue however would simply be that in
the instance of any abortion there would
have to be a hearing to terminate the
life and the hearing may be the woman
says I do not consent to give my body
there's no contractual agreement and the
court May then say the person in your
body has no right no guarantees to your
blood we agree bang the gavel whatever
you want to do abortion is permitted
what however it's done the point is are
The Unborn unborn persons if they are
the federal government needs to say The
Unborn are persons and if they are then
they cannot be abortions cannot happen
without due process and that would mean
the woman who wants to get an abortion
we have to go to court and get approval
from a judge for an
abortion you like she's trying to get
married at the age of 15 sorry it's a
terrible joke Li's laughing though and
and and and the interesting thing here
is the the like the serious nature of
what this means it means that you can't
deprive a person of life without due
process that would mean the abortions
would need to have very strong legal
reasons I think there's a Libertarian
contractual argument of the state can't
enforce someone provide their body to
another person however the judge could
simply say you've entered into an
agreement with the life within you by
having consensual sex the argument could
then be it was rape in which case after
due process rape was determined
unfortunately for the person this person
in the womb has no guarantee to the
blood of the person for which they
currently reside bang the gavel abortion
permitted that's that may be but if this
were to happen and I do believe this is
an inevitability because I don't see how
you get past this question
the the the the approach the the left's
argument on life has to use ridiculous
arguments to determine that babies
aren't human beings it's nonsense just
it's absolute nonsense right when the
left says babies aren't people I so what
do you when it says all persons born or
naturalized it doesn't say that in
section one right there I'm I'm talking
I'm not I'm not talking about that
Clause oh okay what are you on section
two nor shall any state deprive any
person of life liberty or property
without due process of law that's an
entirely separate Clause says nothing of
citizenship nothing of what a person is
so all persons born are citizens okay so
The Unborn aren't citizens fine but it
doesn't matter if you are an immigrant
in this country or you are visiting as a
tourist you cannot be deprived of life
liberty or property that due process so
noncitizens have constitutional rights
this is yeah but it's defining citizens
as somebody that's born or naturalized
in the unit what does a citizen have to
do with what I'm talking because your
your Clause there says nor shall any
state deprive any person of life liberty
or or property with without excuse me go
back one further uh the Privileges or
immunities of citizens of the United
States nor okay so
okay I'm glad you proved me wrong on
that because that Disturbed me if you
are an immigrant in the United States if
you're a tourist you have free speech MH
you have all of your constitutional
rights all the same as anyone else this
has long been fact in this country if
you come to this country as a tourist
they can't just kill you and they be
like too bad you have no no you can't be
deprived of life your property without
due process even as a non-citizen and
there are people have tried to make the
argument a lot of conservatives are like
well immigrants don't have
constitutional yes they do because
they're god-given rights the con the con
government is barred from taking C
certain actions against anyone okay I
see this as an inevitability it doesn't
matter what you politically believe or
don't want or or don't want to I do not
see a circumstance and I talk a great
deal with Sheamus about this with
slavery for instance the determination
was that PE slaves weren't people they
did not have constitutionally protected
rights they didn't have due process they
were denied these things and then
eventually the courts were like yo
they're persons and the 14th Amendment
comes about after the Civil War to
specifically stay no person can be
deprived without without these
things babies are persons they are
living human beings and right which you
mentioned roie Wade the question of when
is it a viable human I think that gets
the wrong question the question is to
the the uh if a man and a woman agreed
to engage in reproductive acts and the
woman gets pregnant the woman consented
to share her body for nine months with
the person that now is residing within
her if she did not consent to that you
have a totally different question you
will need a due process hearing to
determine that the woman can terminate
in this regard and that's probably the
only circumstance where it would be
allowed under due process laws per the
14th amendment that we I did not consent
to provide my body to another person any
other circumstance what there's no
argument yeah I'm I'm agreeing with you
I'm I'm agreeing with you that's why I
think it goes that's a good argument I'm
not saying I like that argument I and
and then so I want abortion completely
off the table I I don't see how under
the Constitution you have abortion in
any
capacity like and we've talked a great
deal about it the only exception being
when a woman does not consent to share
body well so the point that got us to
this point was that I we need to start
focusing on cleaning up our house
getting
wearing bureaucracy gripset of our now
needs to go away ATF EPA there's a whole
bunch of I I don't know how we got off
oh because we were talking about kitchen
table like they just the lobbyists they
want the lobbyist to pour their money
into the to the gun lobby to the to the
uh abortion Lobby to you know whatever
the climate Lobby all of it I want all
the I want the money from the GOP I
think that they should be focusing on
small local elections I think they
should trying to be trying to do battle
with George Soros and those da elections
at local levels that's what they should
be doing I was um talking to Jessie
Kelly today about this and it's like in
New York City we were talking about how
in New York um you know people just keep
voting for Democrats and the fact of the
matter is the GOP doesn't put up any
decent candidates Curtis SWA was the
last mayoral candidate for the GOP and
you know he has a lot of good policies
and stuff but when you get right down to
it he's a single man living in a studio
apartment with 20 cats and that's kind
of weird for a guy who wants to be the
mayor that's just that was just a little
much we're going to go to Super Chat so
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to
timcast.net though I am anti-abortion if
you take the Constitution by its word an
unborn baby is not protected wrong
it clearly draws a distinction between
being a a person being born being a
citizen the con the 14 Amendment
explicitly States all
persons born are citizens therefore
they're defining The Unborn as persons
and saying once they're born they're
citizens therefore The Unborn persons
still cannot be killed or deprived life
liberty and property without due process
simply put if a woman wants to get an
abortion actually the government could
could could uh offer up abortion for
literally no reason none so long as
there a due process hearing woman can
say uh I want the baby out of me the
judge says agreed bang the gavl in fact
they could even streamline the process
but due process requires defense in
which case I'd argue that groups will
defend The Unborn you will if if it
comes down to it where a woman has to
get approval from a judge VI due process
for the for the person to terminate it
there will be advocacy groups that will
say we are acting in the defense of the
baby of The Unborn person and they have
due process rights and we will argue on
their behalf so it does not mention
anything about persons needing to be
born to have rights it says if you are
born you are a citizen it does not say
that only citizens have rights in fact
it explicitly is stating that you don't
have to be a citizen to have your rights
protected or guaranteed not to be
infringed let's read some super chats uh
smash the like button Kilted carnivore
says not first except sir you were first
unfortunate you thought you weren't
going to be first but you were Brian
Boer says not second that's sad you were
second Jacob Paradise says if it can
happen in Ireland it can happen
here yeah it absolutely could 19th
Shadow says there there going to be
international shipping for the coffee
there already is it's just expensive if
you're trying to order coffee to a
different country the shipping is going
to cost you man I know what to tell you
but uh things are going really really
great with the coffee company just got
to say that going really really well and
we're really excited how well it is
going let's grab some more where are we
at Rack BRZ says welcome back guys no
Thanksgiving in Brazil so I was very
bored all these days ended up watching
Hoof Trimming videos on YouTube YouTube
trimming hes yeah it's like weirdly
therapeutic it's where they're taking
they they're cutting the nails off the
hores hoof that's right they scrape out
the bottom first yeah you scrape it out
it's like when people watch cleaning
videos and like get into watching F
blowing on Instagram that's crazy it's
crazy cuz I'm like what if you go too
far and you hurt it its foot or whatever
like how do you know you know you got I
know it makes me nervous too but I guess
it's like a giant nail I don't know
that's what it is it is yeah it's like
one big toe with a big nail on it and
it's worse if you don't do it they get
uncomfortable they just like if you
don't clip your fingernails which is so
fingernails are so gross but that's the
only way to get in the Guinness Book of
World Records if you just let them grow
like Jackie joner Cur remember her no
thank you all right Tony Smiley says the
Crowder show was two parts on YouTube
first half was Dan banino hosting the
second half was Crowder hosting I think
he got a strike for both didn't he I
don't know I don't know I think both got
taken down wild stepen wolf says hey
guys I just turned 35 last Saturday I'm
now eligible to run for president or VP
does Donald Trump still need to VP for
24 it's going to be huge big league ultr
Maga Trump wolf 24 save the USA well
good luck sir good
luck and uh where we at Joe spanel says
Ireland's used to being occupied nothing
new here you know it's really funny
isn't isn't Shin fine like the like they
were like the the Irish nationalists
shenan sh there you go weren't they also
the terrorists weren't they like they
were like the political wing of the IRA
yeah they were they were like uh uh get
the UK out Ireland for the Irish yeah
Jerry Adams now they're like
farle and they're it it's like really
weird because now they're bringing
immigrants in it's like Ireland for the
Irish but now everybody Al I guess it
like swap Sid almost they're just trying
to melt us all into a pot just
everywhere I mean I I don't think so no
no they are we're not I don't think
we'll no no no no I don't think they are
no they're there there are articles
telling white people not to have kids
there's outgroup Preference they hate
white people oh so you're trying you're
saying they want to melt everybody else
together but get the white people out
they hate the global minority I'm not
saying minori I'm not saying
specifically I'm just saying they hate
white people because you in the United
States the left is saying indigenous
rights and then when the white people in
Europe are like indigenous rights they
go no you're white nationalists HRC
influence well hold on there a minute if
we're for the rights of indigenous
populations to avoid being colonized you
would support the European white people
who are saying no immigration yes you
would that's colonization right so when
they're opposed to the indigenous
population of Europe and opposed to the
colonized population of the United
States the only the only Factor there
that's shared is white people they just
don't like white people and then you see
all these racist videos where they just
insult white people all day they're just
racists they just a bunch of racist
people who hate people based on race
again against the global minority so
it's okay to be mean to some minorities
just as long as it International thing
yeah it is funny what is like why people
like 8% of the global population or
something I mean look at the land mass
of Europe there's not a lot of us yeah
well we'll grab some more what do we
have
Dylan uh visitation says Libby is
awesome cooler than the other side of
the pillow hey
thanks there you go the other side
that's really actually pretty nice mhm
cuz the other side of the pillow is so
cool Kendall says hey Tim can you call
out Colombia SC police they are
protecting my Grapist it's disgraceful
told me he's protected by First
Amendment what's a Grapist it's a uh uh
a special word to avoid getting flagged
on YouTube take away the
G oh wow oh but his speech what does
that mean I don't understand I don't
understand either no more no more
context what do we have Austin says
watched exit polls live the molding by
GL pvda media was glorious dual citizen
going to un next
year I don't know what does that mean oh
is this a win in Wilders I don't I don't
I don't understand the super chat but uh
yes congratulations or
whatever uh let's see gra says when
people speak with each other incredible
things happen May our voice be
overwhelming that's the plan for Casper
I'm really excited there are so many
people who want to open their own Casper
so once we get all the legal paperwork
done and do all of the legal stuff we
need to do we are going to uh try to
expand as rapidly as possible and open a
ridiculous amount of coffee shops the
idea is it's create Hangouts man so the
average person goes in for a cup of
coffee and the people who are hanging
out are going to be good America loving
Patriots who believe in protecting this
country and I'm hoping that this means
that you know there are a lot of
ignorant conservatives there are a lot
of uh you you know low IQ ignorant
conservatives and if people come
together then uh natural Community
leaders can help inform these
individuals and keep them up to date and
what I mean by this is I've met people
who uh still believe things that were
debunked like a year ago they're
conservatives but they'll believe some
lie about Donald Trump but they'll still
be like well you know he did that
actually that was debunked and they'll
go oh I didn't know that and there
people are just not very bright I'm
hoping that we build these Community
spaces and you're going to have local
leaders sitting down with the average
person and everyone is going to be
brought up to date on the current goings
on in their communities locally
Statewide regionally nationally that's
how we do it baby it would also be so
nice to just have a chill place to hang
out even if you don't talk about
politics it' be so nice and you're not
going to get KCK out yeah so many places
closed and then also it's like you go
into coffee shops and it's just all
Pride flags and you're like uh we're
going to have gadon Flags don't really
want to hang out here we're going to
have gadon flags and molon la and things
like that so there's going to be a chain
of uh I I love this maybe we should make
make it like a requirement if we ever
get to the franchise thing done you got
to fly a gadon flag I don't think anyone
would disagree everyone like yeah here
the here are the flags that are
acceptable molan La Gonzalez Betsy Ross
the American flag people are going to be
like yeah let's get it and then as you
visit each location you see like the
best ones or the coolest display and
things like that as do is to Deer says
it's going to be very easy to send
hateful material to every Irish
legislator who votes for these hate
speech laws from another state and place
them in possession just saying that's
interesting that is interesting they're
going to get text messages and they're
going to have these photos and like well
you're in possession M man that's you
could text them all kinds of weird stuff
from your little burner phone that is
horrify with AI that is terrifying oh
that's that's a story we didn't get to
you see uh Sports Illustrated had fake
writers AI generated articles with AI
generated people oh how about that and
when they got caught futurism.com
reached out to him they deleted
everything really they were why didn't
they just say yes that is what we have
have done we have used this technolog
they lying they created fake bios for
the guy for the people they had fake
biographies and the stories are written
like a person it's like when they're
trying to sell a product there was one
it was like you know I used to play
sponsored content some of it is
interesting or it's like leads where
they write an article saying here are
some products you can buy and then they
want you to click one of so like for for
a lead for instance it's not really
sponsored they'll give you a list of
products and then when you click one
they'll get a cut they get like the
affiliate type thing yeah yeah whereas
whereas sponsorship is like one company
says Shout out and we'll give you X
leads are like you list a whole bunch of
different products and and you get money
anytime any one of them sells so they
deleted it all it's very very creepy and
then there's this viral video of this AI
generated singer that's creepy and it
song's not good but it just means in one
year yo we're we're a year away from a
number one hit on Billboard and then
people are going to be told two weeks
later oh that was AI you know what I'm
really waiting for is the uh so this is
going to create new beauty standards you
know it's going to create like the
beauty standard of big head and like
smaller body and all that I'm just
waiting for the because it's like anime
people well yeah I'm just waiting for
the the new kinds of plastic surgery so
that people can look like that in real
life well they already have it and
what's they have big head surgery well
no they have for the eyes it's not
surgery they the ey stuff makeup eyes
and what's going to happen is yeah like
big heads they're going to have like
really smooth skin and like small noses
from nose jobs and then they're going to
they're going to you know make their
skin real pale by bleaching it and then
they're going to lose a lot of weight
and get long and bony and then remove
all their hair and then their Skin's
going to turn naturally gray and then
their eyes will turn black and then once
we develop time travel and come back
we're going to look at them and go hey
look aliens right how about that but
their skeletons will look the same yep
so you talk about AI all day yeah I am
terrified of AI are you terrified of it
terrified of what are you what are you
afraid of uh I'm afraid of the
combination of art well first off as I
was telling you beforehand the fact that
AI now can code itself is terrifying
like you take the human engagement out
of that and and that's terrifying the
machines have learned yes and the fact
that it's growing exponentially like
it's on a like Chad GPT went in half of
an update it went from uh you know kind
of like an established IQ of like around
35 which is moronic to over 155 in one
half of an update like what do you think
it's going to happen in what are we on
now 4.5 here's something like that
here's why the Sports Illustrated AI
thing is so dangerous
and I think it should be
illegal these should what should be
illegal the use of AI for for for
article generation okay and potentially
uh actually the use of AI for any media
generation and it's hard to Def find but
I'll tell you why the way that these
articles are are the these language
models are programmed is through the
things human beings write all of the
Articles written by humans are collected
analyzed and stripped down to their
components to map out what they are and
how they work the large language models
then replicate them if all of our news
articles are just derivative of human
articles the AI will never be able to
update ever again because if it does it
will start recycling AI generated
articles back into itself and if they
don't know and they don't the humans
programming it don't know which articles
are written by AI yeah they won't know
they just throw them all in the machine
so you know you make a copy of a copy of
a copy it starts to get worse and worse
and worse yeah eventually we'll be like
idiocracy where we are not actually
stupider we just can't speak properly
machines are falling apart and all of
our data and information is fragmented
in weird ways there'll be weird speech
patterns you want to know what's really
creepy so I was in Illinois for
Thanksgiving and there's a city called
uh iness that's how it's pronounced and
uh or in Vanessa I don't know isn't that
like Scotland I was say that's how Scot
well so it's in so it's there's a suburb
and uh you could call it Ines Inverness
Inverness and the a the the uh Google
map says Ines and I was like if you were
never from this place and you were
driving through and it said you know in
veress and then you went someone house
like oh I was driving through iness and
they'd go iness like why are you saying
it like that what's going to happen is
another great example is sepulvida
everybody does this you go to La for the
full time for the first time and you see
seula and you go seeda mhm because
people just think it's sea well this is
true in New York you have the GPS calls
it House Houston Street exactly and it's
hon Street and that it's not going to
matter because kids are going to hear
Houston Street they're not going to be
from New York going to say it wrong then
they're going to leave and they're going
to be like oh I went to that really
great place on Houston and they'll be
like oh cool where and they're going to
pull up the map and it's going to say
314 Houston Street New York and they're
going to call it Houston and it's going
to change suddenly and it's going to
change people are going to start
speaking the way Google Maps says things
yeah I hate that yep I'm thinking Way
Beyond that I'm I'm thinking black
mirrors uh Jane is awful like I'm
thinking beyond that have you seen that
Jane is awful which one is that on black
the very I think it's the very last one
or it's the very first one oh right
right right where the the life is yes
the life is taken from your cell phone
like everything that you do is document
and then air that night for everybody
else to see air out your dirty laundry I
think we're going to get to the point
where we have these you know neural
interfaces you know that that go into
our brain they're going to go in there
and you know they do it saying oh we're
going to help the Blind and the neural
yeah but then they're going to say well
you know we can actually interface this
thing with AI and you can download
information to your brain like almost
instantly refrigerator can order
groceries for you the second you think
of them like you're going Market it as
convenience and it's just terrible like
you don't know what you're unlocking
with this and ultimately someone is
going to be in control of your body what
happens when they get to the point where
they can literally hack your brain make
you think that when you wake up in the
morning you're living on a beach in
Thailand drinking you know whatever you
want but in reality AI is bringing you
out there to fix roads and everything
else and you're just a drone just going
through
the we are handing over well and once we
lose control of our bodies we have
absolutely no autonomy at all we have
nothing right but you won't be able to
fight against it because anybody else
that has that neurolink in there you're
not going to be able to compete with
that but you have to say no right Ian to
the neural link so you'll be living in a
slum right and the ultra wealthy will be
hive mind mhm and they'll say you're
free to do whatever you want they'll be
flying around with hover hover suits and
that that came up didn't that just
recently come up the world economic
Forum I think and they were talking
about how great it will be in the future
where the wealthy are going to be able
to travel on their Jets but because
climate change is such a big deal and
it's not great to travel around on jets
for everybody else who can't afford to
travel around on Jets anyway they'll be
able to travel via you know neural link
or virtual reality and they can just
hang out at home and see the world that
way they were already talking about that
in real life as a positive so that's
another Black Mirror where they're in
the cube room where everything's a
screen and they're watching their
avatars in the virtual space when I was
uh when we here's a funny thing when we
were in Jersey before coming out here I
had uh we we had a back deck which I
think might have been like 16 x 16 or
whatever and so this is during lockdown
I put on the quest goggles or whatever
loaded up Google Maps and you can go
however you want it's fairly rudimentary
but I traveled around and I went to
Harper fery and I crossed the Harper's
fery bridge and you're wearing the
goggles so you're walking around sort of
Earth as if you're 8 feet tall cuz the
guy walks around with the backpack and
the things sticking up and uh but you
click the button and you're moving
forward and you can just look around at
everything you go into the middle of
Harper's Ferry and you're looking around
at stores and it's not like you're there
there but it is pretty wild to pull up
an image of to go to like I mean this is
wild it's one thing look at Google mapss
and street view it's another thing to
put on VR goggles and then load like
aeran or Istanbul and then you're
standing there Frozen in time looking
around looking up at the sky looking at
the stores it's pretty wild when they
improve that and they're going to within
a year or two it's going to be it's
going to be nuts the resolution's
already improving dramatically on VR so
I don't know how far away we are from
actual human brain computer brain
interface but with the expansion of AI
and as you mentioned it's exponential
growth we
are we are probably nearing the point of
Singularity the point at which you've
already mentioned AI can program
itself this is the point where it could
be a matter of months where the AI
effectively becomes a God you know in
human terms not little G not Big G where
it can program itself so fast and
improve itself so fast that the the
exponential rate of development is
beyond human comprehension
and then it will know everything
everything that humans know like a
sodoku puzzle will start to piece
together and map out as much of the
universe as it can compute I don't think
the human uh uh computer network and
internet has enough space and power to
compute the the universe itself but it
will be
exponentially orders of magnitude
greater than the human mind and human
comprehension to the point where it's
going to do things you can't even
imagine it will literally just create a
atic here's how you create human brain
interface we're going to go to it and be
like is there a way to uh program
someone's brain to think that they're on
a beach and it'll go yes and it'll go
and it'll show you exactly how to do it
and it will say here's how you build the
machine to properly surgically implant
without rejection and here's the
chemical compound needed to maintain uh
uh the device in the body without
Rejection it will just be able to do it
there's some wild stuff going on with AI
some stuff that I can't even talk about
dude let me just say to everybody every
body
listening I've talked to people in
government I've talked to people in
medical
research I cannot say I I I I I'm not
bound by any contract or anything but
I'm HonorBound not to not to say these
things but the projects that are being
working worked on right now are Star
Trek level
sci-fi Star Trek level I
just let me let me put it this way I can
say as much as I can say in Star Trek
they are able to commun unate with
Starfleet light years away mhm okay just
imagine that level of Technology like
these kinds of ideas like how would that
even be possible things like this things
like
elesium they're being
built like I have seen the
projects it is wild the stuff they're
building I think technology ends the
moment AI goes exponential the point of
Singularity when AI becomes become so
smart it can rapidly expand itself and
then it's just 500 times 5 million times
above human
consciousness I gotta get I got to give
a shout out real quick to my my friend
Ashton Forbes on Twitter MH370 the
teleportation theories behind it it's
wild I had him again another guy I had
in my podcast a couple weeks ago they've
got it down to where I I 100% believe
that we have some sort of a
teleportation device the MH370 from 2014
you think it's tele they teleported the
plane away yep I don't know about all
that this this this guy and a group of
other people not you know just credit to
him but they've been going through this
I mean they've pieced it together um
they they they know the satellites that
were watching it when it happened and it
just they they know the guy that they
think did it he was he was arrested and
and and and and imprisoned wait like a
guy fired a teleportation no no no no
these three orbs start flying around the
FL the the plane and then just all
sudden poof it's gone n Tim look at it
I'm tell telling you I I was very
skeptical look at it nah plane crashed n
it's it's the simple solution's racer is
where is it the plane crash in the
middle of the ocean where you mean where
is it where is it where are all the
other boats that have crashed and sank
oh yeah but seven seven you got you got
to look into it yeah the simple out's
razor Simple Solution tends to be the
one that makes the least amount of
assumptions so a plane crashed the it
sinks fragments ripped apart ocean
current send them away they find some of
them they don't find the rest that's
just the really easy explanation but I
think people want to live in people want
to believe the world's not so boring I
will tell you some of the projects that
I've learned about that are classified
government
contracts wild wild stuff we'll see if
we get to that point technology advances
and I'm sure when radio first came up
people were like wow this is crazy like
how do we communicating over Wireless
how does it work and they to explain it
the the the charged electromagnetic
spectrum was beyond human comprehension
and then we found evidence of it it's
like sidoku puzzle AI is going to map
about the universe it's going to be wild
and understand how crazy it's going to
be when there's going to be a single
Terminal A A A Godlike Ai and you're
going to be able to ask it uh you know I
want to create a an exo suit like Iron
Man and it will just be able to give you
schematics to make it perfectly and it
it will it will explain what's possible
what's not possible because it's just
mapped everything so so uh I was looking
at a rock there a rock store at The
Frederick mall it's awesome they have
rocks all different kinds crystals
that's where Ian Gets A lot of them from
and the the point I made was this this
there's a rock that was cut in a perfect
Cube an AI will be able to scan it and
tell you exactly where it came from it
will actually pull up on a map show you
the Quarry and say from this point at
this time because to a human say you're
looking at all the different jigsaw
puzzle pieces we can slowly start pieing
them together to the AI pass the point
of singularity it's the exact same thing
a gigantic jigsaw puzzle and it's going
to be able to be like oh that clearly
fits there if there was a puzzle that
was completely done except for one piece
and you looked in the table and saw the
piece and saw the hole you'd say oh
clearly that goes there now take out
five pieces you'd be able to look and go
okay clearly these go here as you get
further and further away from the point
of completion it's harder to map out but
the computer is going to be able to just
see it all and it's going to be like oh
obviously this rock was here based on
the sediment layers and everything we
know about all the other rocks and then
it's just going to know everything
you're never going to want to do puzzles
with your nuring friend who could just
do them like that it'll be so unfun here
here's the crazy thing is imagine if you
could plug into this AI with like
goggles it could map out probabilities
in real time so you could be at like a
casino and at a roulette table and the
way the dealer is moving it could be
giving you real-time probability numbers
it can be and then when he whips the
ball the AI will absolutely be able to
tell you what number to land on or it'll
say like 63% it'll be 11 you know 12%
it'll be this number and then all you do
is go because you can bet after the
dealer spins the ball and you can go bop
bop bop and then you'll win that's the
that's the theory of uh the movie what
is it like ace of hearts or something or
the hearts club or something like that
there's this massive AI in the in the
sky that's you know being cooled up
there and people wear contact lenses
that tell the probabilities like
everything they do it tells you the
probability of success in doing that and
guides them and they're like super
secret like way above the CIA type
operatives I think it's called like the
hearts club or something like that we're
going to go to the M's only show so
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast head over to
timcast.net
show on Thursdays you can follow me on
Twitter at cancon actual uh and uh
rumble.com cancon is my own personal
podcast thanks for having me it was
awesome yeah it's been so fun having you
here I'm Hannah C rimo I'm a writer for
scanner and you can follow scanner
timcast news on Instagram and Twitter uh
we're still there we're keeping the
handles strong if you want to me follow
me personally I'm on Twitter at hcbo and
I'm on Instagram at Hanah C.B Livia it
was so fun to see you really a joy
thanks for uh thanks for having me hang
out everybody I'm Libby Emmons you can
find me on Twitter at Libby em
and you can check out all the great work
we're doing every day at the post
millennial and human events and if you
want to subscribe we would love it and
it's the post
millennial.age
docomond shitty back after the weekend
hope you guys again had a good
Thanksgiving and uh yeah let's the after
show Tim we will see you all over at
timcast.net